bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
je tiens d'abord à votre nom à souhaiter
la bienvenue à Madame Catherine Jaouen
devenue député de la première
circonscription du Vaucluse le 4 juin
on remplacement de Monsieur Joris Ebra
bienvenue madame
alors la première question donc l'ordre
du jour appelle les questions
gouvernement la première question va
être posée par Madame Nadège à beau
Mongolie pour le groupe LFI
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
madame la Première ministre 15 15
journées de mobilisation massive
historique et populaire organisée par
affront syndical uni solidaire et
déterminé vous pensiez balayer le volet
du peuple si ma plus tard le voici
toujours prêt à batailler l'enjeu est
clair nous voulons abroger votre réforme
des retraites car elle condamne elle
condamne tous les travailleurs et
travailleuses à deux ans de travail de
plus et à des autres plus basses elle
condamne les carrières hachées par les
discriminations hachées par les
exploiteurs elle condamne davantage les
femmes les personnes LGBTI les personnes
en situation de handicap elle condamne
les travailleurs étrangers et toutes les
victimes de racisme elle condamne les
précaires celles et ceux qui subissent
mais ne baisse jamais les bras pour
imposer cette réforme
Osny vous agissez de manière autoritaire
et cela vous conduit au pire piétinement
de nos institutions vous bafouez la
séparation des pouvoirs en décidant de
ce qui peut être débattu ou non en
muselant l'opposition vous remettez en
cause le droit d'abonnement des députés
du jamais vu dans l'histoire vous vous
dites garant de la démocratie mais qui
croyez vous tromper vous sortez de l'arc
républicain que vous avez constamment à
la bouche vois magouilles causeront
votre perte vous accompagner l'agonie de
la Cinquième République vous exécutez la
volonté d'un homme seul qui veut se
mettre le peuple madame la Première
ministre je vous le dis notre peuple
reste debout et digne jamais vous ne le
mettra à genoux et pour cette raison
vous avez déjà perdu la volonté du pape
est ainsi tôt ou tard nous abrogerons
cette réforme des retraites nous
gagnerons alors je vous demande
simplement allez vous cesser de foulé au
pied notre démocratie allez vous écouter
le peuple et renoncer à cette réforme
injustice injustifiée allez-vous laisser
le Parlement voter allez-vous admettre
votre défaite morale et politique
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail de plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci à madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députés vous avez madame la députée
dit que la réforme ne porterait en elle
finalement que les effets négatifs c'est
pourtant cette réforme qui va d'abord
permettre au système de protection
sociale de subsister et donc garantir
aux générations qui viennent une pension
de retraite c'est cette réforme qui va
permettre de revaloriser la pension d'un
million 800 000 des retraités actuels et
de 200000 nouveaux retraités par an
c'est cette réforme qui va permettre
madame la députée de mieux prendre en
compte les carrières longues et
notamment de mieux aider ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 18 ans c'est
cette réforme qui va donner des droits
de nouveau aux femmes ne manquent
notamment celles qui travaillent toute
leur vie et qui vont pouvoir bénéficier
d'une majoration de leur pension dès
lors qu'elles auront atteint l'âge légal
mais qu'il manquera des trimestres
nécessaires pour aller au 43utés qui ont
évoqué il y a une dizaine d'années alors
même que vous étiez membre du Parti
socialiste c'est cette réforme madame la
députée qui va permettre tout simplement
de mentir à ceux qui sont les plus
fragiles d'avoir une retraite de pouvoir
être protégé ce ne sont pas les plus
riches qui ont besoin d'un système de
retraite et d'un système de protection
sociale ce sont les plus fragiles la
responsabilité c'est de résorber le
déficit la résorbe la responsabilité
c'est le sauver le système de retraite
et c'est cette majorité qui le fait
merci beaucoup monsieur le Mina ministre
madame la députée bon écoutez monsieur
le ministre je ne m'attendais à rien
mais je suis quand même déçu dès lors
j'ai m’adresser à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale madame brun Pivet
je vous invite à ne pas écouter ce
gouvernement qui mène le pays droit dans
le mur et à défendre l'Assemblée
nationale le 8 juin lors de l'examen du
texte du groupe yote pour approcher la
réforme de retraite merci madame la
députée monsieur le ministre merci
mesdames la présidente Madame la députés
vous dites je ne m'attendais à rien et
je suis pourtant déçu il y a un fait que
vous avez oublié de rappeler la
commission d'affaires sociales avait
voté vous avez perdu
je vous remercie ministre
je vous indique madame la députée que
lorsque je préside les questions au
Gouvernement il est d'usage que je ne
prenne pas par au débat et je vous
remercie de ne pas m'interpeller
la parole est à monsieur le Président
pencheur pour le groupe
madame la Première ministre l'usage
généralisé par le gouvernement d'outils
d'obstruction les articles 47 1 44 2 44
3 l'article 49.3 l'Assemblée nationale
et l'article 38 au Sénat pour faire
adopter votre réforme des retraites
injustes sans véritable vote témoigne
dans détournement manifeste et inédit de
notre démocratie après ces procédures
que vous avez cyniquement utilisé pour
bâillonner le Parlement une première
sous la Cinquième République vous avez
ajouté à la crise sociale une crise
institutionnelle vous deviez apaiser
mais vous avez jeté de l'huile sur le
feu vous deviez apaiser mais vous nous
avez insulté en nous traitant
d'irresponsables et de menteurs vous
êtes érigé en membres du Conseil
constitutionnel ce que vous n'êtes pas
en effaçant la séparation des pouvoirs
je voulais solennellement madame la
Première ministre vous mettez en garde
ainsi que les présidents de groupe qui
cautionnent cette funeste stratégique
qui va créer une jurisprudence empêcher
désormais les groupes parlementaires de
déposer des propositions de loi qui
auront le moindre impact financier je
voulais vous rappeler l'article 3 de
notre Constitution la souveraineté
appartient au peuple français qui la
délègue à ses représentants nous les
députés ainsi que l'article 24 le
Parlement vote les lois nous votons les
lois le général de Gaulle expliquait que
notre Constitution c'est des
institutions une pratique vous ne
respectez pas ces bonnes pratiques vous
ne respectez même pas le père de la
Cinquième République la démocratie est
notre bien le plus précieux notre groupe
est de nombreux autres députés sur nos
bancs veulent la préserver madame la
première ministre quand allez-vous
apaiser notre pays en laissant enfin les
députés voter la loi
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Bertrand pencher
vous portez à son paroxysme l'art du
paradoxe
premier paradoxe devant les Français
vous avez soutenu des candidats à la
présidentielle qui défendait la retraite
à 65 ans
et de
depuis quelques mois vous êtes le
porte-voix d'une alliance contre nature
de la France insoumise au rassemblement
national hostile à toute mesure
permettant de garantir le financement de
nos retraites
deuxième paradoxe ce sont vos alliés de
la nupesse qui sur instruction du leader
de la France insoumise au sciemment
empêché l'assemblée de débattre et de
voter sur le cœur de la réforme
[Musique]
et vous prétendez maintenant avec cette
proposition de loi que ce débat pourrait
se tenir en quelques heures monsieur le
président Bertrand penchère vous le
savez et monsieur le député de Courson
grand défenseur de la rue rigueur
budgétaire le 7 au 6 votre proposition
de loi est inconstitutionnelle elle
aggraverait lourdement les charges
publiques réduiraient les recettes elle
méconnait frontalement l'article 40 de
notre Constitution et avec vos alliés
insoumis vous persévérez dans une
deuxième atteinte à notre constitution
de contrôle de la recevabilité a été
dévoyée à des fins uniquement partisanes
et aujourd'hui dans une nouvelle
atteinte au principe même de notre
démocratie vous prétendez
ignorer un vote clair et net en
commission des affaires sociales qui a
abrogé le premier article de votre
proposition de loi
alors cette proposition de loi sera
débattue jeudi en séance publique je ne
vais ni anticiper ni présenter ses
débats à venir mais ils doivent avoir
lieu dans le cadre fixé par notre
Constitution Gaston monerville que vous
aimez citer disait que Violet la
Constitution s'est attentée au droit
même des citoyens alors monsieur le
Président pencher la démagogie permet de
faire les gros titres mais elle conduit
au déceptions au colère et au rejet de
la politique comme de nos institutions
alors respectez la Constitution
respecter les 100 175 heures de débat
parlementaires respectez le vote des
députés en commission monsieur le
Président pencher mettez enfin vos actes
en cohérence avec vos propos
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame le Premier ministre vous deviez
apaiser le pays vous continuez à jeter
de l'huile sur le feu tout ça n'est pas
responsable
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Présidente
berger pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ça a commencé
par des brimades sur mon poids en classe
je recevais des stylos des coups de
compas dans le dos je me prenais des
gifles et des insultes pendant 6 ans je
n'ai parlé à personne j'avais trop honte
j'avais trop peur et puis j'ai décidé
d'en finir j'ai acheté un litre d'alcool
à brûler je l'ai répandu sur mes
vêtements et je me suis mis le feu
j'avais 16 ans
ces mots sont ceux de Jonathan destin
victime devenu figure de la lutte contre
le harcèlement scolaire décédé en août
dernier et dont je veux ici saluer la
mémoire et le combat
[Applaudissements]
son combat doit être le nôtre ces drames
individuels sont aussi des drames
collectifs le suicide de l'Insee qui a
mis fin à ses jours à l'âge de 13 ans en
étain je veux en notre nom à tous lui
rendre hommage et adresser nos
condoléances à sa famille et à ses amis
mais aussi lui adresser nos excuses
parce que ses enfants sont nos enfants
Lucas Thibault Chanel ou Dina ils ont
mis fin à leur jour à l'âge de 10 ans 13
ans ou 14 ans pour que le harcèlement
cesse ses enfants se sont nos enfants
Les enfants de la République qui aurait
dû les protéger nous tous nous les
adultes la communauté éducative les
autres élèves ce qui voit mais ce thèse
par crainte des représailles nous les
parents car si un enfant est harcelé
cela veut bien dire qu'il y a des brutes
pour le harceler nous l'État par le
travail implacable de nos forces de
l'ordre et de la justice puisque nous
avons justement créé un délit de
harcèlement scolaire nous tous pour être
à l'écoute pour voir les signaux pour
leur permettre de parler pour ne jamais
après prendra la légère la douleur d'un
enfant parce que ça commence toujours
par une première insulte une première
humiliation une première gifle et que
nous ne devons rien jamais laissé passer
madame la Première ministre quel mot
voulez-vous adresser aux parents
endeuillés quelles actions pour que plus
aucun parent n'est à connaître un pareil
drame je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente la
parole est à madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Aurore Bergé les mots que
vous venez de lire sont déchirants
le harcèlement est un fléau qui mine le
quotidien de milliers de jeunes et
causent trop souvent des drames la
détresse la dépression est parfois même
le suicide
le décès de Lindsay en est un terrible
exemple et je veux ici dire toute ma
solidarité et mon soutien à sa famille
et à ses amis
[Applaudissements]
alors oui le harcèlement peut tuer et
c'est intolérable madame la Présidente
Aurore berger je connais votre
engagement ancien résolu et constant
dans la lutte contre le harcèlement je
sais également qu'il est largement
partagé sur tous les bancs de cette
émission car une car sur une question si
grave il ne peut pas y avoir de clivage
nos écoles nos collèges nous lisser
doivent être des lieux de savoir et
d'ouverture contre l'ignorance et les
préjugés des lieux où chacun est protégé
alors nous agissons dès 2019 nous avons
expérimenté sur la base du volontariat
le programme de lutte contre le
harcèlement phare ce programme c'est un
réseau de 400 référents à travers le
territoire c'est la création d'un
protocole de prise en charge des
victimes avec des élèves ambassadeurs
dans chaque établissement et avec la
sensibilisation des parents comme des
professeurs ce programme le ministre de
l'éducation nationale papenga l'a rendu
obligatoire à la rentrée 2022 dans
toutes les écoles et dans tous les
collèges je connais son engagement qui
est aussi le mien mais nous devons aller
plus loin nous allons faire de la lutte
contre le harcèlement la priorité
absolue de la rentrée 2023
nous allons étendre le programme phare
au lycée nous allons désigner dès la
rentrée dans chaque collège un adulte
référent dans la lutte contre le
harcèlement nous allons protéger
davantage les élèves victimes en
primaire en ouvrant par décret la
possibilité d'écarter d'une école un
élève auteur de harcèlement nous
rendrons obligatoires la formation des
personnels contre le harcèlement nous
augmenterons les moyens des plateformes
d'alerte et d'écoute enfin j'ai demandé
au ministre de l'intérieur de la justice
et du numérique d'appuyer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale afin d'être plus
efficace dans la prévention et les
sanctions contre le harcèlement
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux madame
la Présidente Aurore berger tout acte de
harcèlement est intolérable nous devons
rien laisser passer ensemble nous
continuons à nous mobiliser pour
protéger notre jeunesse je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à madame la Présidente Le
Pen pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre la fraude au
prestations sociales est une réalité
vécue par les Français elle brise le
consentement à l'impôt casse la
confiance dans l'action publique simple
la fois dans notre contrat social
surtout elle condamne à terme le
financement de notre protection sociale
la Cour des comptes en 2019 et 2020 a
tenté de chiffrer les fraudes sociales
j'ai bien dit tenté elle serait de 10 à
25 milliards d'euros elle relève en
particulier le cas des cartes vitales en
surnombre qu'elle estime à plus de 3
millions les gestes comptent en 2022
plus de 73 millions d'assurés sociaux
pour un peu plus de 67 millions
d'habitants la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale explique que tout va bien c'est
mignon de cartes vitales en trop
appartiendrait à des personnes décédées
ou qui ont quitté le territoire la E4
vitale fluidifierait le dispositif
serait minime selon ses dires et la
carte Vitale biométrique serait trop
coûteuse bref il serait urgent de ne
rien faire
pourtant les cartes vitales circulent à
foison et ne sont pas forcément utilisés
par leur bénéficiaire légitime quant au
professionnel de santé il ne vérifie pas
les identités les cartes vitales prêtées
les usurpations d'identité font partie
du paysage seul la carte Vitale
biométrique peut y remédier pourtant
lors de la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement n'avait pas fait preuve de
naïveté me semble-t-il lorsqu'une
personne utilisait le passaginal d'un
tiers elle s'exposait à une amende de
1000 euros
la réalité
et que la biométrie est l'unique moyen
de réserver la prise en charge des soins
au seul personnes légitime nous devons
écouter les mises en garde de la Cour
des comptes et de l'Inspection générale
des finances ce sont les personnes
modestes qui souffrent en premier lieu
des difficultés financières de la
protection sociale lesquelles entraîne
mécaniquement crise de l'hôpital désert
médicaux et des remboursements madame la
Première ministre allez-vous aller enfin
au-delà des mots merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Le Pen
alors je vous le confirme notre modèle
social est au cœur de notre pacte
républicain et frauder c'est spolier les
Français qui contribuent honnêtement
c'est fragilisé nos services publics et
c'est mettre en cause ce pacte social
c'est bien pourquoi le ministre en
charge des comptes publics a annoncé ces
dernières semaines un plan d'action
global contre la fraude fiscale et
contre la fraude sociale et je vous
confirme madame la Présidente Le Pen
nous sommes déterminés à agir contre
cette fraude fiscale avec des moyens
supplémentaires notamment 1500
personnels de plus avec une augmentation
aussi des moyens techniques de 25%, nous
renforçons également les sanctions avec
un nouveau délit pénal des travaux
d'intérêt général pour les frondeurs
condamnés à une peste d'amende et comme
il s'agit souvent d'un phénomène
international nous voulons initier une
copie fiscale sur le modèle de la COP
climatique et puis contre la fraude
sociale nous AG avons aussi nous
recrutons mille agents supplémentaires
nous investissons un milliard d'euros
pour moderniser nos systèmes
d'information nous renforçons à la fois
le contrôle de ceux qui ont droit des
prestations comme des professionnels et
je vous remercie madame la Présidente de
m'avoir donné l'occasion de redire notre
détermination et les moyens que nous
mobilisons alors s'agissant des cartes
vitales s'agissant des cartes vitales
madame la Présidente Le Pen je regrette
que vous n'ayez pas entendu les
déclarations du ministre en charge des
comptes publics car il se trouve que
nous avons naturellement pris en compte
l'alerte sur les cartes vitales sur
numéraire que ces cartes vitales ont été
désactivées qu'aujourd'hui il en reste
quelques centaines mais vous avez un
pouvoir de contrôle donc je vous invite
à vous en saisir donc ces cartes vitales
ont été désactivées et par ailleurs nous
partageons aussi le souhait de pouvoir
assurer que chaque bénéficiaire de sa
carte d'une carte et bien l'utilisateur
de la carte Vitale c'est pourquoi le
ministre de l'Intérieur et le ministre
en charge des comptes publics
travaillent conjointement pour
rapprocher la carte vitale et les titres
d'identité donc vous voyez madame la
Présidente Le Pen je vous remercie à
nouveau de m'avoir donné l'occasion de
redire la détermination du gouvernement
à lutter contre la fraude fiscale et
sociale je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la Première ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Inaki et Shiny's
pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre j'aurais pu reprendre
mot pour mot la question que j'ai
moi-même posée le 26 juillet dernier
j'interrogeais alors les ministres de
l'économie et du logement sur la
spéculation immobilière qui frappe d'un
bon nombre de notoires depuis 10 mois on
passait et la crise du logement ne fait
que ça graver à votre conscience de la
situation que le ministre du Logement
qualifie de bombe social s'oppose
l'inconscience de votre inertie
l'ensemble des acteurs du logement était
suspendu aux annonces du gouvernement
dans le cadre du CNR sur le logement
mais beaucoup de bruit pour rien vous
passez à côté de vos propres ambitions
si ce CNR a permis de mettre la question
du logement au cœur de l'actualité les
réponses que vous apportez sont soit
insuffisantes soit décevantes et ce
n'est pas le constat d'un simple élu de
l'opposition mais celui d'une majorité
d'acteurs de la Fédération du bâtiment à
la Fondation Abbé Pierre difficile
d'égaler un tel naufrage et ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit mais un ancien ministre
du Logement construction rénovation
accès à la propriété logement social
prix du foncier mal logement spéculation
encadrement des meubles tourisme les
enjeux sont multiples et mériteraient
une vraie loi de programmation à cela
vous pouvez vous préférez répondre par
une kyrielle de nouvelle réflexion
superposa des rapports eux-mêmes
héritiers de multiples concertations
surtout à cela vous préférez sous
couvert de ce plan logement faire 2
milliards d'euros d'économie encore une
fois en sacrifiant le Pinel et le prêt à
taux zéro sans proposer d'alternative
efficiente il est temps de prendre votre
responsabilité sur ce sujet de
préoccupation quotidienne pour les
Français votre désintérêt favorise les
maxi propriétaires et desserts les plus
modestes et les classes moyennes madame
la ministre il y a des dossiers qui vous
semblent prioritaires les drapeaux
devant nos mairies les réformes des
retraites dont personne ne veut le
contournement toujours plus indécent des
pouvoirs parlementaires dont nous aurons
encore une brillante illustration ce
jeudi si vous mettiez autant d'énergie à
traiter le sujet du logement qu'à
empêcher les députés de voter les
constats seraient bien différents à côté
de votre manque de clairvoyance se pose
la question de votre cohérence le
logement occupe une place centrale ainsi
qu'un débattre en nous
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Naki shanise oui le CNR hier c'est
conclu sous la présence de madame la
Première ministre que je me remercie et
non le logement ne fait pas partie des
grands oubliés du gouvernement ni du
gouvernement précédent j'en veux pour
preuve j'en veux pour preuve le plan
logement d'abord qui a été lancé par le
Président de la République et le
gouvernement précédent qui a permis de
mettre à l'abri sous un toit 440 000
personnes sous le quinquennat précédent
j'en veux pour preuve le doublement de
l'action de la rude qui est passé de 5
milliards à la fin du quinquennat
socialiste monsieur le député à 12
précédent j'en veux pour preuve le
lancement de ma prime rénov qui a été un
élan sans précédent sur la prise en
compte de l'état des logements de ce
pays et les annonces de madame la
Première ministre hier sont à des
besoins et seront complétés dans les
jours qui viennent ils sont à la hauteur
des besoins parce que nous avons
préservé le PTZ pour accéder au logement
dans les zones tendues et donc permettre
des logements importants parce que nous
avons nous avons le souhait de relancer
de manière massive le bail réel
solidaire qui est un moyen d'accéder au
logement pour les plus fragiles je
m'étonne d'ailleurs que vous soutenez le
Pinel qui est comme vous le dites dans
la deuxième partie de votre question un
outil pour les multiples propriétaires
alors que à l'inverse nous soutenons le
logement intermédiaire qui est un bon
outil d'accession à la location pour les
classes moyennes et et pour permettre du
mouvement dans les dans le parc HLM
enfin j'en terminerai mais j'ai d'autres
questions sur le sujet donc ça me
permettra de compléter j'en terminerai
avec le pack de confiance que nous
allons conclure avec le monde HLM avec
la nécessité de produire plus et de
rénover parce que la rénovation est au
cœur de notre action merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Charles
zitchange tool pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre ma question s'adresse
au ministre porte-parole du gouvernement
jeudi dernier la commission d'enquête
relative aux ingérences étrangères à
voter le rapport de notre collègue
constance le grip qui sera publié dans
quelques jours
nous savons tous dans quelle
circonstance
cette commission d'enquête a été
commandée par les apprentis sorciers du
rassemblement national
personne ici n'a été dû de cette
tentative d'instrumentalisation de notre
assemblée par une extrême droite qui
voulait se blanchir de ces liaisons avec
la Russie Vladimir Poutine
bien mal leur a pris
tant le retour de flamme semble encore
douloureux aujourd'hui pendant les 5
mois d'audition nous avons assisté cher
collègue au meilleur comme au pire
le meilleur ce furent nos fonctionnaires
les agents des services de renseignement
les enseignants chercheurs les
journalistes qui ont rendu compte des
tentatives de déstabilisation de notre
démocratie venant notamment de la Russie
de la Chine et du Moyen-Orient qu'en
pensent le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre le pire ce furent les
confirmations des liens tout
particuliers de l'extrême droite
soi-disant patriotes avec une puissance
étrangère la Russie de Monsieur Poutine
des liens intenses et anormaux car oui
de multiples auditions
[Musique]
entre la galaxie le pénis et le système
de Moscou lors de sa propre audition
Madame Le Pen à une nouvelle fois
propager la propagande du Kremlin et
réitérer son soutien à l'invasion russe
de la Crimée en 2014 fameuse année où le
Front national contractait son emprunt
de 9 millions d'euros
auprès d'une banque chez Corus alors
monsieur le ministre monsieur Véran
comment le gouvernement juge les menaces
d'ingérence dans notre démocratie et
comment mieux protéger notre
indépendance nationale
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Charles
season Stone
une ingérence étrangère en France c'est
comme une poupée russe d'abord
s'appellent les intérêts français à
l'étranger Poutine le fait
ensuite pratiquer la désinformation à
grande échelle Poutine le fait enfin et
surtout interférer dans une élection en
investissant sur un candidat qui vous
serait favorable la question à laquelle
votre commission d'enquête devra
répondre c'est Poutine a-t-il fait la
deuxième question qu'il faut se poser
c'est dans quel but Poutine ferait-il de
l'ingérence en France pas par amour de
nos valeurs républicaines de notre art
de vivre la française certainement pas à
l'évidence ce serait pour affaiblir la
France et l'Europe de l’intérieur
poupées russes et donc aussi cheval de
Troie vous m'interrogez monsieur le
député sur les liens que vous suspectez
entre l'ingérence russe et le
rassemblement national la lecture de
votre rapport de commission d'enquête
sera sans doute éclairante mais avant
cela les liens entre le rassemblement
national de Madame Le Pen et la Russie
de Vladimir Poutine sont connus elle y
est allée quatre fois en 5 ans elle n'a
jamais caché son admiration pour le
dirigeant russe allant jusqu'à
d'ailleurs affiché son visage souriant
une fois n'est pas coutume sur un tract
de sa campagne présidentielle pour le
patriotisme
où est-ce que c'était du cynisme est-ce
que c'était du cynisme parce que pour
vous la fin justifie les moyens et
qu'importe qu'importe puisque une fois
présidente vous seriez redevable à celui
qui aurait contribué à vous faire élire
Madame Le Pen puisque plus que Monsieur
Poutine et votre banquier c'est donc que
pour lui vous êtes un placement moi je
crois que c'était du sinistre j'en parle
au passé puisque monsieur Poutine a
désormais disparu des tracts du
rassemblement national des personnes est
dupes et certainement pas vos troupes ou
Pérusse cheval de froid de 3 mais aussi
pantin de Monsieur Poutine voilà
monsieur le député à quoi ressemble une
ingérence étrangère aujourd'hui en
France
la parole est un monsieur Marc Le Fur
pour le complet républicain merci merci
madame la Présidente
madame ma première ministre une très
grave crise de la construction et de
logement est devant nous
vous étiez hier devant les
professionnels de l'immobilier et de la
construction je ne vous apprends rien
vos propos ont énormément déçus cette
déception est partagée par tous de la
Fondation Abbé Pierre aux artisans de la
Fédération du bâtiment en passant par le
monde HLM vos propositions ne sont pas
du tout à la hauteur de la crise
violente qui touche ce secteur en
supprimant le dispositif Pinel vous tuez
l'investissement locatif privé en
supprimant le prêt à taux zéro sur la
construction neuve sur 90% de notre
territoire vous portez préjudice au
monde rural aux petites villes aux
villes moyennes et vous accentuez la
facture de notre pays
en multipliant les normes et en
réduisant les aides vous interdisez
l'accès à la propriété aux classes
moyennes se faisant vous organiser leur
déclassement la propriété de leur
résidence et bien souvent une sécurité
pour pour leur vieux jours je vous
rappelle que 90% des Français aspirent
vivre dans une maison individuelle alors
plutôt écouter nous madame madame la
Première ministre notre président de
groupe Olivier Marleix vous l'a dit
mardi dernier mettez un moratoire sur le
zan le fameux zéro artificialisation
nette les Français ne connaissent pas
encore ce sigle mais nos mères le
connaissent et savent que ce sigle est
en train de figer complètement le
développement de leur commune madame la
Première ministre sortait de cette
culture de gauche qui rejette
l'accession la propriété et qui refusent
la maison individuelle et prenez des
mesures d'urgence
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre de la Ville et du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés Monsieur le Député
Marc Le Fur
oui il y a une crise du logement et nous
le savons et nous y travaillons oui
cette crise elle est multifactorielle
elle ne sera se résoudre qu'avec de
l'argent public je vous pensais moins
dépensier et plus attentif aux deniers
publics oui il faut résoudre cette crise
du logement tous ensemble c'est le sens
du Conseil national de la refondation
que nous avons mis en place quelques
exemples nous avons décidé de permettre
à la Caisse des Dépôts habitat d'acheter
17000 logements et de contribuer à la
relance de la promotion immobilière nous
avons dans le cadre de la convention
quinquennale qui sera signé dans
quelques jours avec Action Logement
permis l'acquisition de 30000 logements
qui permettra lui aussi la relance de la
promotion immobilière car nous le savons
la promotion immobilière produit tout à
la fois de l'habitat privé et de
l'habitat social nous faisons un pari
celui du logement intermédiaire et je
pense que vous devriez être à nos côtés
pour promouvoir le logement
intermédiaire qui est le logement qui
permet le lien entre l'emploi
et le logement oui nous faisons à Paris
celui du br.s le bail réel solidaire qui
permettra l'accession à la propriété des
classes moyennes et des classes
intermédiaires un pari que l'on sait
déjà gagnant oui nous savons aussi qu'il
ne faut pas renvoyer les Français vers
le surendettement parce que c'est un
risque je suis bien placé pour savoir le
drame des copropriétés dégradées donc la
copropriété est une bonne solution si
les personnes ont les moyens de
rembourser leur prêt à la banque et leur
charge de copropriété et pour baisser
leur charge de copropriété nous faisons
le Paris massif de la rénovation 80% des
logements qui existent sont déjà là et
nous savons que c'est en rénovant
massivement le logement notamment en
copropriété que nous réussirons je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur Le Fur
monsieur le ministre son agit fort 80%
des Français aspirent à vivre dans une
maison individuelle ne n'y est pas
l'aspiration non que patriote sortez de
votre bulle
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
personne ne dit la qualité résidentiel
des zones pavillonnaires il faut les
respecter bien évidemment continuer à
les accompagner et c'est ce que nous
faisons avec ma prime rénov je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
je vais maintenant passer la parole à
Monsieur le Président brotherson que je
voudrais féliciter pour son élection à
la présidence de la Polynésie française
il s'agit de sa dernière question au
gouvernement donc il aura un traitement
de faveur et pourra reprendre la parole
pour faire ses adieux à notre assemblée
après sa question au gouvernement et je
sais que vous aurez tous à coeur de
l'écouter monsieur le Président vous
avez la parole merci Madame un
présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des Armées la
Polynésie française c'est 5 millions de
kilomètres carrés mais en termes de
contrôle de la navigation aérienne c'est
12 millions de kilomètres carrés du fait
des accords qui nous lient au pays de la
région Pacifique cette navigation
aérienne est contrôlée donc par des
services territoriaux et par des
services de l'État qui sont aujourd'hui
confrontés à un paradoxe en effet le
seul radar monoaples qui est aujourd'hui
sur le mont marron donc sur les hauteurs
de F1 à a est en cours de démantèlement
ce démantèlement et va être remplacé par
l'utilisation de satellites couplés à
des qui sont embarqués sur les aéronef
qu'on appelle des aDSB aujourd'hui ce
mode de fonctionnement est tout à fait
efficace sauf que l'ensemble des
aéronefs civils et bien équipé de ces
adssb des petits coucou des aéroclubs
jusqu'au jet liner et les seuls aéronefs
à vrai dire qui ne sont pas équipés d'un
DSB aujourd'hui sont ceux de l'armée
cela pose un problème réel de gestion de
la circulation aérienne en Polynésie
puisque c'est bâtiments de l'armée sont
souvent amenés à faire des évacuations
des évacuations sanitaires à faire des
projections sur le territoire et
aujourd'hui donc on est dans
l'incapacité de suivre efficacement
leurs mouvements donc ma question est
simple que compte faire le ministère des
armées pour résoudre ce paradoxe
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est à madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président brotherson alors d'abord pour
répondre à votre question le contrôle de
la circulation aérienne à Tahiti est
actuellement assurée par un radar qui
sera prochainement remplacé par un
système satellitaire qui équipe tous les
avions civils en revanche les aéronefs
militaires obéissent à des règles
spécifiques pour des questions de
sécurité mais nous sommes conscients de
l'enjeu que vous soulevez et le
ministère de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer se saisit du sujet mais plus
largement à l'heure vous quittez votre
mandat de parlementaire et la présidence
de la délégation aux outre-mer je
voudrais vous dire quelques mots tout
d'abord pour vous féliciter de votre
victoire aux élections en Polynésie
française alors il pourrait paraître
étonnant que la première ministre de la
République salut l'élection d'un
responsable politique au vu aussi
éloigné des siennes sur un sujet aussi
majeur que l'indépendance d'un
territoire de la République mais
monsieur le président brotherson je
connais en vous un parlementaire
profondément respectueux un opposant
ferme mais attaché au débat démocratique
et toujours prêt au dialogue c'est aussi
le cas de nombre de vos collègues du
groupe de la gauche républicaine et
démocrate nos choix politiques sont
profondément éloignés mais notre
attachement aux valeurs de la démocratie
et de la République nous rassemblerons
toujours
alors monsieur le Président brotherson
vous avez depuis un an fait vivre la
délégation aux outre-mer avec une grande
maîtrise en sachant faire travailler
ensemble des élus de territoire et de
culture politique diverses je le sais
les attentes de nos compatriotes
ultramarins sont immenses et je veux le
dire nous serons au rendez-vous il reste
beaucoup de travail je le sais au-delà
de l'engagement du ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outre-mer et du
ministre délégué aux outre-mer tout mon
gouvernement y prend part je réunirai
dans quelques semaines un comité
interministériel aux outre-mer qui
actera des décisions d'urgence mais
aussi des mesures de moyen terme
monsieur le Président de roserson enfin
je voudrais vous dire que nous espérons
pouvoir avoir avec le gouvernement de la
Polynésie française et vous-même des
échanges sereins concrets répondant aux
attentes des Polynésiens vous avez eu
des mots clairs au lendemain de votre
élection pour dire que rien ne serait
pire que des débat précipiter ou
superficielle j'adhère pleinement à
cette approche les questions qui se
posent sont majeures nous ne chercherons
pas à les contourner mais nous devons
prendre le temps de converger sur une
méthode à travers vous monsieur le
Président je veux enfin saluer
l'ensemble des parlementaires
ultramarins et des habitants de la
Polynésie française nous aurons
l'occasion de nous revoir rapidement
pour travailler au développement et à la
prospérité de ce magnifique territoire
du Pacifique je vous remercie
merci madame la Première ministre
monsieur le président
je vous remercie de vos mots très
gentils madame la Premier ministre chers
effectivement le 12 mai dernier j'ai été
élu président de la Polynésie française
c'est un trajectoire de vie que je
n'avais pas prévu le petit garçon qui
surfait
usé ses fonds de culottes sur les bancs
du collège de fiti à houriné ne
s'attendait pas un jour à siéger parmi
vous et encore moins à devenir un jour
président de la Polynésie mais la vie
après tout c'est ce qui arrive pendant
qu'on fait des plans
en tout cas
depuis mon mandat mon premier mandat en
2017 j'ai appris à découvrir cette cette
maison prestigieuse c'est couloirs
chargé d'histoire c'est mur qui s'il
pouvait parler nous rencontrer encore
plus d'histoires et j'ai appris à
découvrir des hommes et des femmes tous
attacher aux valeurs de la République
aux valeurs de la démocratie
alors
filmer toujours aujourd'hui un peu
difficile de comprendre votre passion du
droit
[Rires]
passion qui est partagé sur tous les
bons de manière un peu cyclique et
périodique
j'avoue que j'ai toujours été
impressionné par la ferveur des débats
et je pense que vous avez chacun vos
convictions chevillées au corps
cette assemblée elle est représentative
du peuple français dans sa diversité les
outre-mer sont là également pour
rappeler que cette France elle n'est pas
qu'exagonale elle est une géométrie bien
plus vaste que le simple hexagone
géométrique on a tendance à parfois
oublier ici je souhaite que dans le
futur cette dimension
ultra-marine soit mieux intégrée dans
les réflexions dès la conception de nos
lois qu'on ne se pose pas la question à
posteriori de qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
Outre-mer dans la loi qu'on vient de
voter c'est le vœu que je formule et
puis
à l'adresse de du gouvernement
gouvernement si on se penche un peu sur
l'étymologie du terme ça vient du latin
globet en arrêt qui veut dire tenir le
gouvernail naviguer piloté alors pour un
polynésien est pris de navigation
traditionnelle ce sont des termes qui me
parlent mais ça traduit finalement une
une impérieuse nécessité d'un mouvement
permanent et ça va parfois à l'encontre
du je crois du recul nécessaire et je
voulais juste partager avec vous pour
finir le la traduction du mot
gouvernement en Réauté chez nous
gouvernement se dit
ça veut dire la paix voilà
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Hendrick Davy
pour le groupe LFI
madame la Présidente chère collègues
parcoursup est devenu synonyme
d'angoisse l'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur est aujourd'hui un parcours du
combattant madame la ministre comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là c'est simple
Emmanuel Macron comme c'est
prédécesseurs démolites tous nos
services publics et nos acquis sociaux
vous condamnez les plus âgés à
travailler deux ans de plus et
aujourd'hui lors de la 14e journée d'une
mobilisation historique les salariés
vous le répète pour eux c'est non
vous privez la jeunesse du droit a
poursuivre des études supérieures aussi
en organisant la sélection avec
parcoursup parcoursup genere stress et
angoisse pour les élèves mais aussi pour
leurs parents et leurs enseignants
depuis mercredi dernier les lycéens ont
accès au premier résultat pour ceux qui
ont obtenu la formation de leur choix
c'est un soulagement et la fin des
incertitudes mais pour les autres ils
devront attendre plusieurs mois avant
une réponse définitive et l'angoisse
s'intensifie de jour en jour certains
quittent donc la plateforme renonçant à
trouver une place dans le public et
s'inscrivent dans des formations privées
à la qualité vous le savez madame la
ministre parfois douteuse au final l'an
dernier plus de 100000 jeunes sont donc
restés sur le carreau à l'issue de
parcoursup ce sont souvent les élèves
des milieux les moins favorisés qui font
les frais de cette sélection on empêche
certains des étudiants de poursuivre
leurs études on casse le service public
et on favorise des écoles privées dont
les effectifs ont augmenté de 10% à un
an l'année dernière en un an c'est un
contresens historique nous avons besoin
de qualifications dans tous les domaines
pour faire face aux immenses enjeux
sociaux et écologiques le savoir
critique à l'université est essentiel
aussi pour l'émancipation des citoyens
et pour la démocratie la démocratie au
lieu de mettre tout le monde en
compétition il serait beaucoup plus
efficace de refonder un vrai service
public de l'orientation et de redonner
des moyens à l'université pour
accueillir tous les étudiants
la seule façon de rassurer vraiment
notre jeunesse c'est de garantir une
place pour chaque bachelier dans le
domaine de son choix et des conditions
dignes pour poursuivre les études ma
question est simple quand l'université
bénéficiera-t-elle de la grande loi elle
attend besoin il faut une garantie
d'autonomie des repas gratuits des
logements pour les étudiants recruter
des enseignants et bâtir des universités
qu'attendez en nous merci beaucoup la
parole est à Madame Sylvie Retailleau
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche merci madame la Présidente
messieurs et mesdames les députés
monsieur le députés d'avis alors vous
avez fait le choix de ne voir évidemment
que des défauts de parcoursup et bien
sûr aucune amélioration c'est faire bien
peu de cas monsieur le député des
travers du passé d'ailleurs d'abord que
je veux rappeler l'entre-soi
l'autocensuravé par la hiérarchisation
la course à l'inscription avec des files
d'attente interminables ou encore pas si
loin on l'a connu le tirage au sort pour
des filières en tension votre question
et je voudrais vous en remercier et donc
l'occasion de vous montrer que nous
avons au contraire fait évoluer
parcoursup sur la transparence sur
l'accompagnement humain mais aussi sur
l'efficacité car pour nous il s'agit de
mieux informer de mieux conseiller et
bien sûr aussi de rassurer oui il faut
de la transparence c'est le message que
je passe aux enseignants et responsables
du supérieur qui ont toute ma confiance
on est loin des soupçons permanent de
discrimination que vous faites peser sur
eux là où il n'y avait rien nous avons
expliqué les attendus puis rendu
obligatoire l'affichage des critères et
cette année complètement refondu leur
présentation enfin je m'étais engagée à
ce que la face d'admission soit plus
courte pour réduire la tente et ce
stress des lycéens et de leur famille
cette année la phase principale est
passée de 35 jours contre 108 jours en
le matin il y avait plus de trois quarts
des lycéens qui ont déjà reçu une
proposition d'admission ces 10 points de
plus que l'an dernier voilà ce que nous
faisons je voudrais finir par vous dire
qu'à côté de votre posture souvent de
dénigrement systématique à côté des
soupçons de pratiques discriminantes que
vous faites peser sur les enseignants
qui vont partir des commissions des vœux
et bien nous travaillons à améliorer
justement les pratiques de parcoursup
pour justement c'est la seule solution
pour réduire le stress des élèves et des
parents plutôt que les discours merci
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric Falcon
pour le rassemblement national
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues en
introduction je voudrais dénoncer la
méthode qui consiste à interpeller une
vis une présidente de groupe qui ne peut
répondre à des attaques indignes et
honteuses monsieur zidolstools vous
n'avez même pas lu ce rapport vous êtes
lamentable vous êtes la honte de cette
assemblée
la France
la France est entrée dans une crise du
logement sans précédent dans les zones
tendues l'offre de logement notamment
locative est insuffisante pour répondre
à la demande des Français cette crise
touche avant tout les Français les plus
modestes contrairement à vos
affirmations cette crise du logement
n'est pas conjoncturelle et bien le
résultat de l'absence d'une politique du
logement ambitieux depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron les taux
d'intérêts ont été relevés le secteur du
bâtiment fait face à l'inflation des
matières premières que vous êtes bien
incapables d'endiguer mais la réelle est
première cause et la multiplication des
normes que vous imposez la complexe ro
2020 ou encore l'application 110
arnement du Zéro artificialisation nette
qui gratifie la disponibilité du foncier
ont entraîné un effondrement de la
construction des logements neufs 370 000
livraisons sont attendus en 2023
seulement 275 000 pour l'année 2024
alors que nous vrions construire 500 000
par an après avoir sinistré le secteur
de la construction vous vous attaquez au
parc de logements anciens en interdisant
en interdisant progressivement la
location de logement présentant un DP au
GF puis e selon l'Insee sans travaux de
rénovation près d'un logement sur deux
ne sera plus autorisé à la location en
Île-de-France dans les années à venir
vous organisez à grand coup de Nord
énergétiques fondés sur des DP aux
critères discutables l'effondrement de
l'offre locative à la dépossession des
petits propriétaires qui voient la
valeur de leur bien dépressifs mais
n'est pas là l'objectif finalement
Macron lui qui ne jure que par la
finance la bourse n'a de 16 d'attaquer
la propriété mobilière aura signé portée
par une économie réelle dont donc
délocalisables donc non délocalisables
depuis 2017 vous avez raboté les appels
le prix atout zéro supprimer l'appel
accession réduit les dotations des
bailleurs sociaux et vous apprêtez à
supprimer le Pinel madame la Première
ministre allez vous revenir sur les
normes intenables que vous imposez à
l'immobilier et Renault français les 15
milliards d'euros de la politique de
logement que vous leur avez confisqué je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Frédéric Falcon
d'une certaine manière nous ne sommes
jamais déçus sur votre capacité à
exploiter une crise parce que oui crise
du logement elle est réelle mais vos
réponses sont bien insuffisantes
l'objectif du gouvernement l'objectif du
gouvernement et bien sûr de loger tous
les Français quel que soit l'état de
leur compte en banque l'objectif du
gouvernement c'est de sortir un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes de passoire
thermique dans lequel il est
insupportable de vivre en été parce
qu'il y fait trop chaud en hiver parce
qu'il est fait trop froid cet objectif
il a été commencé par le gouvernement
précédent en mettant en place ma prime
rénove la map priver rénov est un succès
c'est 1,5 millions de chantier qui ont
été réalisés depuis 2020 jamais à aucun
moment dans l'histoire de ce pays autant
de chantiers de rénovation ont été mis
en oeuvre
ce dispositif est un succès parce que il
permet aux propriétaires qu'ils soient
bailleur ou occupants d'avoir les mêmes
aides pour rénover leur logement et donc
nous ne sommes pas en train comme vous
le dites de spolier quelques
propriétaires bailleurs au contraire
nous les aidons alors qu'ils peuvent
bénéficier d'un loyer pour loger leur
locataire et donc comme ils ont un loyer
ils doivent réaliser ses travaux de
manière urgente
évidemment nous sommes attentifs à tous
les pièges un piège serait qu'un certain
nombre de logements passent leur
thermique puisse basculer dans le meublé
touristique et bien évidemment nous nous
donnons les moyens ça sera le cas avec
un une PPL qui a été déposé
transpartisanes à la rentrée qui
interdira qui a un meuble étonné
alors que c'est une passoire thermique
et évidemment c'est aussi une priorité
du gouvernement les accompagnateurs
rénovent seront augmentés pour que
chacun sache qu'il doit faire dans son
logement pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
des travaux de rénovation à la fois
performante et globale pour sortir
toutes ces passoires thermiques je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Marion pour le groupe Renaissance merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre délégué
chargé des PME du Commerce de
l'Artisanat et du Tourisme Olivier
agrégoire la tenue de la semaine
nationale de l'artisanat du 2 au 9 juin
me donne l'occasion de rappeler que avec
plus de 1 million 800 000 entreprises et
plus de 3 millions d'actifs le secteur
de l'artisanat joue un rôle clé dans le
développement économique que français le
gouvernement a été attentif à la
situation de nos artisans durement
frappé par les crises successives
pêle-mêle citons les dispositifs d'aide
comme le bouclier tarifaire
l'amortisseur électrique la stratégie
nationale en faveur des métiers d'art
présentait la semaine dernière le
soutien l'apprentissage et la réforme
des lycées professionnels qui ont
vocation apporté des réponses aux
difficultés de recrutement citons enfin
la mobilisation exemplaire des
conseillers à la sortie de crise dans
les directions départementales des
finances publiques les artisans de leur
côté ont su réagir en faisant évoluer
leur mode de production en adaptant
leurs horaires de travail en imaginant
de nouveaux services ils ont prouvé leur
agilité cependant malgré ses actions la
première entreprise de France reste
fragile dans ma circonscription de
Loir-et-Cher les boulangers continuent
d'être menacés par les pénalités de
rupture importantes en cas de changement
de contrat d'énergie par ailleurs de
nombreux professionnels subissent la
concurrence déloyale de plateformes qui
bénéficiant d'une forte mise en valeur
de la part des grandes enseignes propose
de mettre en relation des particuliers
pour diverses prestations information
mensongères des sites internet absence
de garantie des scénales ou de précision
sur les compétences du prestataire de
service prestations payées en liquide
qui échappent à toute fiscalité les
dérapages sont nombreux enfin si les
artisans s'intéressent de plus en plus à
l'actionnariat salarié pour fidéliser
leur personnel ou favoriser la
transmission d'entreprise force et de
constater que les dispositifs actuels
dont sont souvent exclus les SARL sont
peu adaptés à leurs besoins alors
quelles actions madame la ministre
comptez-vous mettre en place pour
limiter la concurrence déloyale qui
fragilise nos artisans et pour apporter
plus de souplesse à celles et ceux qui
souhaitent innover dans la gestion de
leur entreprise je vous remercie mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la Présidente quand vous
faites travailler un artisan vous
achetez plus qu'un service vous achetez
des centaines d'heures d'échecs et
d'expérimentation vous achetez des jours
des semaines des mois de frustration et
aussi de purement de joie vous n'achetez
pas quelque chose vous achetez un
morceau de cœur une parcelle dame une
part de la vie de quelqu'un j'emprunte
ce texte évidemment pas de moi un
artisan de la rue piétonne principale de
Saint-Jean-Pied-de-Port pour le
lancement de cette semaine nationale de
l'artisanat monsieur le député Marion
je profite de votre question déjà pour
remercier la présidente du Parlement qui
a inauguré ce matin la semaine des
métiers de l'artisanat ici même à
l'Assemblée nous avons le plaisir
d'avoir ici des artisans des apprentis
le président des chambres de métiers de
l'artisanat en tribune que nous pouvons
je crois toutes et tous salués nos
artisans nos apprentis nos forces vives
cher député Marion vous l'avez mentionné
les difficultés ont été nombreuses cet
hiver nous avons ensemble collectivement
réussi à mettre en place des aides mais
surtout à informer pas moins de 31 000
boulangers qui ont été appelés
directement par les chambres des métiers
et d'artisanat nous restons avec Bruno
Le Maire extrêmement attentif bien sûr
alors si tu as Sion nous avons été
présents nous continuerons à être
présent vous avez aussi monsieur le
député Marion mentionné des pratiques de
mise en relation directe il est vrai sur
les plateformes nous sommes très
vigilants avec la Direction générale de
la consommation de la concurrence et de
la répression des fraudes la DGCCRF j'ai
lancé il y a dit une dizaine de jours
l'application signal conso qui a été
téléchargé pas moins de 100000 fois je
suggère à nos compatriotes qui seraient
victimes d'arnaque de les déclarer
directement en ligne pour que nous
puissions effectuer des contrôles mais
surtout sanctionner ces pratiques
abusives enfin le temps est court sur la
transmission je recommande la
je vous recommanderai une autre fois
merci merci beaucoup madame la ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Alexandra Martin
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale oui le
suicide de l'INSEE et me la France
entière et a démontré une fois de plus
les chèques de votre politique de
prévention contre le harcèlement
scolaire et votre manque de
considération nous pensons à cet instant
à l'INSEE et aux trois autres victimes
du harcèlement depuis 2021 Dina ambre et
Lucas et à leur famille le harcèlement
scolaire est un des nombreux symptômes
d'une violence sociale grandissante
notamment chez les plus jeunes partout
elle doit être combattue avec force en
dépit de l'adoption de la loi visant à
combattre le harcèlement et le
cyber-harcèlement la tendance ne faiblit
pas dans chaque classe ce sont trois
élèves qui y sont confrontés les
répercussions sont colossales échec
scolaire désocialisation et pour 61%
d'entre eux pensaient suicidaires les
harcèlements des quatre jeunes victimes
étaient pourtant connues encore
aujourd'hui les familles se sentent
désespérément seuls comme depuis le
début de leurs alertes le programme de
prévention phare s'avère impuissant
madame la Première ministre pire absent
dans de nombreux établissements vous ne
reconnaissez pas l'ensemble des élèves
de la République le droit d'étudier dans
un environnement protégé de vivre en
sécurité alors Aurore berger qui aurait
dû les protéger d'abord la puissance
publique
quand responsabiliserez-vous enfin les
auteurs et leurs parents comme je
l'appelle de mes vœux en matière de
délinquance des mineurs vous avez
annoncé que les mesures d'éloignement du
harceleur est une solution de dernier
recours la victime subit alors la double
peine
responsabiliser c'est faire prendre
conscience au harceleur de son délit
c'est à lui qu'il revient de quitter
l'établissement pas à la victime
[Musique]
quant à la communauté éducative quand
sera-t-elle formée pour ne plus
considérer le harcèlement scolaire comme
une affaire d'enfants quand sommes-nous
les réseaux sociaux d'agir quand
prendrez-vous les mesures pour garantir
le droit et l'année d'Abd d'étudier en
sécurité merci ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur pas pendji et
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Alexandra Martin vous avez raison de
souligner que le harcèlement est un
drame c'est un drame pour notre école
c'est un drame pour notre pays et nous
devons nous mobiliser pour cela c'est ce
que le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale fait depuis 2019 d'abord de
manière expérimentale dans six académies
le programme auquel vous faites allusion
a été étendu à l'ensemble des académies
pour les écoles et les collèges à la
rentrée 2022 et il le sera pour les
lycées à la rentrée 2023 est-ce que la
situation est satisfaisante est-ce que
le programme s'est déployé partout de
manière homogène la réponse est non nous
avons du chemin à faire je l'ai dit je
l'ai répété je veux bien vous le dire
une nouvelle fois c'est un travail
patient c'est un travail qui demande de
la mobilisation c'est un travail qui
demande des moyens et nous sommes et
nous faisons deux des questions de
harcèlement une priorité d'abord par les
enquêtes administratives qui sont
diligentes par l'Inspection générale des
sanctions s'il y a lieu pourront être
prises nous le verrons un certain nombre
d'enquêtes sont en cours ensuite par
l'extension des programmes de prévention
de détection et de prise en charge ça
veut dire notamment la formation des
personnels également des moyens
supplémentaires pour les numéros 30 18
et 30 vins qui recueillent une grande
audience un référent rémunéré dans
chaque collège à partir de la rentrée ne
s'occuper que des questions de
harcèlement les dépôts des plaintes
suivantes en cela la loi ballanant qui
seront systématisés dès la nouvelle d'un
harcèlement avéré ou suspect le
déplacement de l'élève harceleur dans le
premier degré jusqu'à présent ça n'était
pas possible j'ai signé le décret qui
est actuellement au Conseil d'État la
formation des personnels et enfin la
mobilisation générale contre le
cyber-harcèlement voilà la réponse merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Marie-Charlotte Garin pour
le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
vous trompez de cible nous allons vivre
un été infernal tous les voyants sont au
rouge sécheresse hivernales nappe
phréatique au plus bas feux de forêt
précoce et vous pendant ce temps GPS
espion caméra de surveillance marquage
codé sur la peau alors il y a pas
d'argent magique mais qu'est-ce qu'il y
en a quand il s'agit de réprimer les
militants vous mettez au service
d'intérêt privé un arsenal judiciaire et
policier sans précédent une gabegie
d'argent public pour protéger une
poignée de privilégier comme vous avez
réprimé les syndicats et les mouvements
ouvriers votre offensive contre les
militants qui défendent nos biens
communs est inédite alors avec vous sans
surprise à chaque fois c'est la même
devise dur avec les gens faibles avec
les puissants
vous ne jouez pas avec le feu vous
faites pire que ça vous démarrez les
incendies et vous vous déchaînez contre
nous parce que vous avez peur vous avez
peur parce que nous sommes de plus en
plus nombreux à nous soulever et pas que
des grands méchants radicaux comme vous
le prétendez nous sommes infirmières
scientifiques ouvriers étudiants
philosophes agriculteurs artistes vous
avez peur de nous nous les raisonnables
nous les défenseurs du vivant alors
comme d'habitude vous allez sur jouer la
caricature flirter avec le mensonge nous
serions les violents nous serions les
irresponsables mais la vérité monsieur
le ministre c'est que les militants que
vous traquez et arrêtez on le courage
que vous n'avez pas le courage de dire
non à l'agrobusiness de dire non à ceux
qui ne veulent pas perdre leur privilège
le courage de protéger nos biens communs
alors Monsieur le Ministre quand
allez-vous enfin faire preuve de courage
quand allez-vous changer de cible
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
je sais pas bien compris l'objet de
votre question puisque
[Musique]
je crois que vous étiez parti pour
m'interroger sur les interpellations des
personnes qui ont saccagé l'usine
Lafarge et je constate que vous avez dû
réfléchir entre temps puisque vous avez
dû constater alors que c'est sous
l'autorité des magistrats indépendants
pays que les policiers de la République
fonctionnent
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame Garin je crois qu'on vous
entendant monsieur le ministre on
comprend très bien qui vous protéger et
qui a vos faveurs
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
je propose madame la députée qu'on évite
les procès d'intention que vous parliez
clairement je pense que c'est ce que
vous devez à vos électeurs pardon de ne
pas comprendre que lorsque vous avez
dans un pays des magistrats indépendants
qui ouvrent des enquêtes soit parce que
on a tenté à l'avis des gendarmes c'est
le cas à Sainte Soline et vous n'avez
aucun mot de compassion pour ces notes
très nombreux blessés
soit parce que l'on saccage des musées
dont on voit bien très bien le lien avec
la défense de l'écologie
soit parce qu'on attend au bien et non
madame la députée vous n'avez pas la
majorité morale et politique pour
imposer vos idées à la République
française madame la députée il faut
accepter que vous n'avez pas de
supériorité morale pas plus que
n'importe quel autre citoyen et les
policiers les gendarmes ne font qu'
appliquer les lois que nous votons et
que vous votez ici ont voulu par le
peuple français et qu'il n'y a pas
madame la députée ce qui serait le camp
du Bien et les autres il n'y a que la
République française que des magistrats
indépendants et que des policiers
gendarmes qui font leur travail ne vous
en déplaise
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Perrine Goulet pour
le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire des
tâches chargée de l'enfance madame la
ministre le Comité des droits de
l'enfant des Nations Unies vient de
rendre ses observations sur
l'application de la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
par la France il me sort impossible de
balayer ici l'ensemble du rapport mais
la délégation droit des enfants aura
l'opportunité de vous entendre le 21
juin prochain les politiques en matière
de protection des enfants connaissent
depuis six ans un regain d'intérêt et
d'activités ont une place à part dans
l'action publique cela les Nations Unies
le reconnaissent le souligne et le salut
à l'instar de la pérennisation de votre
portefeuille ministériel
si tous les enfants avaient connaissance
de leurs droits ils obligeraient les
adultes à les respecter madame la
ministre nous pouvons être satisfait
collectivement des conclusions de ce
rapport mais si dans cette matière il
faut toujours remettre le l'ouvrage sur
le métier je suis convaincu que nos
efforts collectifs nous permettront
encore de progresser et ce rapport nous
montre le chemin pouvez-vous préciser à
la représentation nationale quelles sont
les prochaines actions que vous entendez
mener avec le gouvernement en faveur des
enfants et surtout en matière
d'appropriation par les enfants de leurs
droits je vous remercie merci beaucoup
ma chère collègues la parole est à
Madame Charlotte cobel secrétaire d'État
chargée de l'enfance
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la délégation des droits
des enfants mesdames messieurs les
députés le gouvernement français était
très attendu par cet évaluation de la
France sur le respect du droit des
enfants devant le comité de l'ONU dans
des plaies à tous ceux qui ont critiqué
la France le rapport est quand même
plutôt laudatif notamment sur la qualité
de la préparation mais surtout sur la
qualité de l'action des gouvernements
depuis 2017 le rapport souligne bien sûr
la création d'un secrétariat d'État
dédié à ça mais aussi la création de
votre délégation et l'implication tous
les pouvoirs publics pour faire
respecter le droit des enfants le comité
a salué l'ensemble des avancées
législatives fort nombreuses pour le
respect de la protection des enfants et
du droit des enfants dans le précédent
quinquennat dans la vie réelle que dans
la vie virtuelle sur le numérique et
dans toutes les problématiques de
violence faites aux enfants la stratégie
de lutte contre les violences faites aux
enfants a été saluée j'en ferai un bilan
demain en Conseil des ministres et je
donnerai évidemment des perspectives
puisque nous avons encore beaucoup de
choses à faire comme en témoignent
l'histoire de triste histoire de l'Insee
nous devons encore mieux faire pour nos
enfants et ce rapport sera au cœur du
comité interméal de l'enfance que je
tiendrai le 15 juin au nom de la
première ministre bien sûr nous avons le
sujet des enfants en situation de
handicap les situations des enfants en
situation de pauvreté les enfants
migrants les enfants des territoires
ultramarins tous ces sujets sont au cœur
des priorités de l'ensemble des membres
du gouvernement nous nous y aiderons
vous évoquez madame la question de
Madame la député la question du droit
des enfants et de leurs connaissances
droit des enfants le ministre
d'éducation nationale pousse le
passeport éduc droit qui est évidemment
très important pour les enfants des
collèges la Défenseur des droits
poussent les jeunes ambassadeurs du
droit des enfants dans quelques semaines
la présidente réunira le Parlement des
enfants et je suis sûr que nous serons
tous au bancs pour répondre aux
questions au gouvernement des enfants
nous serons tous très présents sur cette
action importante nous sommes donc au
rendez-vous des droits des enfants le
rapport du Comité nous oblige nous
serons continuer dans les prochaines
années à nous y atteler pour répondre
encore mieux merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Vincent des coeurs pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
fragilisé par la crise sanitaire Camille
leur personnel a rude épreuve n'osaient
pas doivent en outre faire face à des
difficultés de recrutement qui les
contraignent à recourir à l'intérim dans
le coup excessif grève plus encore leur
budget monsieur le ministre il y a
urgence à agir et si on veut éviter la
multiplication des fermetures de lit ou
pire encore de certains établissements
qui risquent de se retrouver sous peu en
cessation de paiement ces établissements
ne peuvent pas attendre plusieurs mois
encore la grande réforme du grand âge
régulièrement annoncé sans cesse reporté
aussi je souhaiterais que vous puissiez
nous indiquer quelle mesure contre
mettre en oeuvre le gouvernement pour
aider les EHPAD à surmonter cette crise
sans précédent rassurer leur
gestionnaire leur personnel les aînés et
leurs familles
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
con ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
des cœurs vous faites état d'une
situation dégradée de nos établissements
pour personnes âgées depuis quelques
mois la réalité c'est que l'État
soutient massivement les EHPAD depuis
plusieurs années maintenant je
reviendrai pas sur l'ensemble des
crédits qui ont été délégués pendant la
crise sanitaire la compensation des
augmentations liées aux Ségur de la
santé l'augmentation des effectifs
d'infirmières de nuit l'augmentation
aussi des temps de médecins
coordonnateurs dans ces établissements
qui étaient nécessaires c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans une période
d'inflation la situation est toujours
difficile vous avez cité les tensions
sur les recrutements liés à intérim il y
a un taux d'occupation aussi qui est
très bas dans nos EHPAD et contre cela
nous avons choisi des mesures beaucoup
plus ciblées on a délégué en fin
d'exercice dernier 440 millions d'euros
pour soutenir le financement des EHPAD
dont 100 millions juste pour l'inflation
on a étendu le bouclier tarifaire sur le
gaz et l'électricité à l'ensemble de ces
établissements et via la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 on a augmenté les financements des
EHPAD de 5,1%. j'ai demandé à l'ensemble
des directeurs généraux des ARS de
suivre la situation des EHPAD qui sont
en difficulté je l'ai déjà dit ici dans
cette assemblée on ne laissera aucun
EHPAD en difficulté ou aucun EHPAD
contraint de fermer on a doublé voire
triplé sur certains territoires les
crédits reconductibles pour autant on
voit bien que les difficultés subissent
subsistent notamment celles liées à la
section hébergement de ces
établissements sections qui dépend des
financements des départements je suis en
lien conscient constant avec les
départements pour trouver des solutions
et permettre aux établissements d'être
mieux financé j'ai demandé j'ai saisi
l'ensemble de mes administrations pour
pouvoir mettre en place un groupe de
travail sur l'évolution avec les
départements pour travailler sur
l'évolution du modèle économique des
EHPAD parce que je pense que seule une
réponse structurelle permettra
d'apporter les financements nécessaires
et de maintenir également
l'accessibilité de l'offre c'est
important on sait qu'on a un
sous-financement aujourd'hui de l'aide
sociale à l'hébergement merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur Decker
oui monsieur le ministre je suis heureux
de vous dire que votre réponse n'est pas
à la hauteur des enjeux l'enjeu c'est
l'attention qu'on doit porter à nos
aînés c'est la reconnaissance qu'on doit
au personnel qui les entourent monsieur
le ministre la question de la solidarité
entre les générations c'est un devoir et
non une option
mon cher collègue la parole
est un monsieur le ministre de
l'Industrie je souhaite aborder
aujourd'hui la décision du groupe Leduc
de renoncer à la construction d'une
nouvelle
usine Bridor fabrication de
viennoiseries en Bretagne Louis Leduc
voici un enfant du pays qui emploie 30
000 personnes dans le monde qui fait le
choix d'investir 250 millions d'euros
dans notre pays et ainsi créer 500
emplois directs qui induit 1500 emplois
indirects le gouvernement français
souhaite réindustrialiser la France
comment passer de la parole aux actes
ce cas d'école pose au décideurs les
problématiques du moment
artificialisation des sols consommation
de l'eau pratique durable liées à
l'import-export est-il acceptable de
laisser le groupe Leduc partir investir
ailleurs dans l'Union européenne alors
que nous sommes soumis au même enjeux de
transition écologique et d'économie
décarbonée dans tous les États membres
de l'Union européenne enfin la
persistance des recours et des
contentieux à perpétuité voulue par
quelques activistes peuvent-ils avoir
raison de l'initiative entrepreneuriale
et de la volonté politique de concilier
économie et écologie alors que toutes
les procédures ont été respectées et les
autorisations administratives accordées
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre chargé de l'industrie
Benoît merci pour votre question et
merci aussi pour votre application dans
ce dossier qui est important dans votre
département même si je sais qu'il n'est
pas spécifiquement dans votre
circonscription le dossier auquel vous
faites référence la nouvelle usine à
livrer était un dossier
environnementalement complexe avec de la
zone humide 36 espèces protégées des
enjeux vous l'avez dit de consommation
d'eau de réutilisation d'eau et tout ça
tous ces obstacles ont été levés en
grande partie grâce aux efforts de
l'Industrielle je dois le reconnaître
qui a accepter de baisser sa
consommation d'eau dans le cadre de son
projet mais aussi des services de l'État
qui ont 13 mois on n'est pas encore tout
à fait au neuf mois que nous souhaitons
mettre en œuvre dans le cadre du projet
de loi industrie verte que j'ai
l'honneur de porter avec Bruno Le Maire
mais on n'est pas loin 13 c'est mieux
que 17 on a réussi à obtenir
l'autorisation vous l'avez dit
suite à cette autorisation juillet 2022
un certain nombre de recours ont étant
déposés ces recours sont non suspensifs
l'un d'entre eux a déjà été rejeté il en
reste 4 et suite à ses recours Louis
auduff a décidé de surseoir d'abandonner
ce projet et de l'installer ailleurs
décision que je regrette j'ai échangé
nous avons échangé avec ces équipes je
n'ai pas encore eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec lui je suis à sa disposition pour
tirer toutes les leçons de cette
expérience et y compris la France est
grande la Bretagne est grande lit les
Vittel ni la vilaine pardon et grande
aussi pour examiner avec lui d'autres
projets potentiels cela dit je tiens
quand même à mentionner que le sujet
Bridor est une exception aujourd'hui qui
confirme plutôt une règle de
réindustrialisation de la France pour un
projet Bridor malheureusement abandonné
nous avons un projet assez sec un projet
au lossolis un projet de STMicro
électronique confirmé par Bruno Le Maire
hier qui va s'installer à Crolles en
Isère nous réindustrialisons la France
nous devons le faire de manière plus
efficace et je vous engage dans le cadre
du projet de loi industriel verte y
compris à regarder ce sujet très
important des recours pour voir si nous
pouvons améliorer les procédures de
manière à faire encore mieux merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre monsieur
Benoît
je remercie naturellement le ministre
pour sa réponse monsieur le ministre je
souhaite de tout cœur que le
gouvernement avec les services de l'État
les acteurs du territoire puissent
retisser les liens avec nos
entrepreneurs et plus particulièrement
là avec lui Leduc il n'y a pas de raison
qu'en France nous ne réussissions pas ce
pari de la réindustrialisation la
volonté est là et nous avons encore plus
de responsabilités lorsqu'il s'agit de
groupes familiaux et d'entrepreneurs
français merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Mélanie
Thomas pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre il y a un peu plus
d'un an vous étiez nommé première
ministre avec ce souhait du président de
la République agir sans relâche pour les
Françaises et les français pour entre
autres la santé et la Renaissance
démocratique où en êtes-vous de cette
promesse sur la santé quand on se
prépare encore une fois à compter nos
morts dans nos hôpitaux ou manque les
soignants et ferment les services
d'urgence ou en êtes-vous de cette
promesse sur la santé quand les
maternités des territoires ruraux
périphériques comme à Carhaix Landerneau
Guingamp menace de fermer temporairement
définitivement faute d'anesthésiste
la crainte d'indément tellement par
service est réel un carré presque un
tiers des lits sont fermés sans
garanties de rouvrir quand il n'y a pas
d'alternative pas de clinique pas de
médecine de ville suffisante toute
suspension ou fermeture partielle est
une atteinte potentielle à la vie
d'autrui une atteinte grave au pacte
républicain notre santé et nos hôpitaux
brûlent d'un système à bout de souffle
que vous ne réformez pas c'est un
renoncement terrible les citoyens ou le
sentiment d'être abandonnés dans une
stratégie de pourrissement ou en
êtes-vous de cette promesse de renouveau
démocratique quand votre majorité
relative n'a qu'à l'esprit d'éviter un
vote sur la réforme des retraites en
confondant créativité constitutionnelle
et mise en danger des droits du
Parlement
ou en êtes-vous de cette renaissance
démocratique quand vos budgets ne sont
pas adoptés que par 49,3 et hier soir
encore chaque loi de règlement et
rejetée par notre assemblée dans le
monde Réal celui des collectivités des
associations des entreprises quand une
assemblée vote contre le quitus
suffisant financier l'exécutif
démissionne en somme cette année vous
n'avez eu de cesse d'agir sans relâche
contre les Françaises et les Français
madame la Première ministre qu'en est-il
de cette promesse que le Président de la
République faisait à votre égard
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement est chargé
du renouveau démocratique
madame la présidente madame mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
je vais tâcher de répondre à l'ensemble
des questions madame la députés parce
qu'elle touche à des secteurs que Serge
je connais bien mais
merci c'est très agréable
madame la député vous interrogez d'abord
sur la méthode la méthode moi vous savez
je crois aussi aux chiffres
la plupart des textes qui ont été
présentés l'écrasante majorité des
tailles qui ont été présentés par la
première ministre et son gouvernement
depuis un an ont été adoptés par le
Parlement vous-même madame la députée
vous avez eu l'occasion et merci pour
cela de voter favorablement sur un
certain nombre de projets de loi et
c'est tant mieux on ne pourrait pas
concevoir les Français ne pourraient pas
concevoir quand on brait d'accord sur
tous les textes néanmoins il y a
quelques textes sur lesquels on peut
avoir des désaccords le texte sur les
retraites en fait partie mais d'autres
textes ont été adoptés avec les voix de
la droite sans la gauche et d'autres
avec les voix de la gauche sur la droite
vous savez ce que je crois profondément
même la députée c'était que c'est le
souhait des Français qui nous ont confié
une majorité relative que nous demandait
pour la première fois depuis des années
des décennies de chercher
systématiquement des accords avec la
gauche et la droite pour faire avancer
le pays ce que on peut déplorer ensemble
c'est peut-être les outrants c'est
peut-être les excès c'est peut-être les
postures qui parfois grève les débats au
Parlement et ailleurs mais je peux vous
dire que je vais à la rencontre des
Françaises des Français comme vous
madame la députée et qui attendent un
parlement que ce soit en bonne maison du
peuple et de la démocratie un endroit où
on soit capable de se parler en fait
d'échanger et de se dire parfois on
n'est pas d'accord mais parfois on peut
par exemple vous savez avoir
systématiquement des députés de ce
côté-là de l’hémicy qui hurle et qu'un
ministre parle pour lui couvrir la voie
ce n'est pas un très bon exemple
d'hygiène démocratique vous voyez je
pense qu'après un an à travailler tous
ensemble on doit être capable de
commencer à revoir un peu les méthodes
et les dysfonctionnements pour se dire
que ce dont les Français ont besoin
c'est de l'apaisement quand ensuite
quand il s'agit ensuite des priorités
vous avez cité la santé on pourrait
citer l'éducation vous êtes un peu une
boîte à Meudon monsieur le député dès
que je parle vous hurler
s'il s'agisse de la santé l'éducation de
la protection des Français du pouvoir
d'achat et bien nous avançons dans une
direction qui est celle que nous ont
confié les Français et encore une fois
il y a pas de raison qu'on ne soit pas
capable de tomber d'accord madame la
députée sur beaucoup de ces textes c'est
le cas dans les collectivités des
socialistes qui ont toujours participé
merci monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
je donne la parole à Monsieur Jean René
Cazeneuve apporteur général pour le
groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie et
des finances au préalable je voudrais
revenir sur le rejet hier en hémicycle
des projets de loi de règlement 2021 et
2022 parce que une fois de plus leur
rassemblement national et la nupes ont
voté ensemble ensemble contre un arrêté
comptable ensemble contre un arrêté
quand un document budgétaire nécessaire
pour l'administration et pour nos
fonctionnaires ensemble contre les
intérêts de notre pays ici il y a ceux
qui sont contre tout et ceux qui sont au
travail pour l'intérêt de nos
concitoyens
monsieur le ministre je voudrais revenir
sur la décision de l'agence SNP de
maintenir la notation de la dette
française cette confirmation est un
signal positif pour notre pays elle
conforte notre stratégie de réforme afin
d'atteindre le plein emploi elle
conforte les choix économiques que nous
avons fait depuis 2017 elle conforte
enfin la trajectoire de maîtrise des
finances publiques que nous nous sommes
fixés mais cette notation nous engage
elle nous engage car oui nous devons
absolument assurer la bonne exécution de
cette trajectoire oui nous devons
absolument
accélérer le désenchantement de la
France dont on sait qu'il est un poison
pour les générations futures oui nous
devons ramener le déficit en dessous des
3% d'ici 4 ans oui nous devons maîtriser
la croissance de nos dépenses publiques
dès le prochain budget il en va de notes
crédibilité il en va de notre capacité à
investir massivement en particulier sur
la transition écologique monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous détailler
votre stratégie pour tenir notre
trajectoire de maîtrise de la dépense
publique pouvez-vous nous assurer que
les propositions concrètes de réduction
des dépenses seront faites dès le
prochain PML PNL je vous remercie je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
général la parole est un monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
rapporteur général comme vous l'avez dit
l'agence dotation standard d'un Bourges
a pris la décision de maintenir la note
de la France inchangée ce qui est un
signal positif la reconnaissance du
travail que vous avez engagé
personnellement que toute cette majorité
a engagé pour rétablir les finances
publiques et la reconnaissance la
crédibilité du travail qui était fait
depuis 2017 quand nous sommes sortis de
la procédure pour des visites excessifs
et revenus sous les 3% de déficit avec
la première ministre Elisabeth borne
avec le président de la République nous
sommes totalement déterminés à tenir
notre trajectoire de finance publique
avec fermeté et dans la clarté la plus
totale ça suppose d'abord de continuer à
avoir une croissance positive là où
certains de nos voisins affichent
désormais de la récession nous avons de
la croissance nous continuons à créer
des emplois et nous ouvrons des usines
dans notre pays
c'est le résultat de notre politique
économique
le deuxième pilier de notre stratégie
c'est de sortir définitivement du quoi
qu'il en coûte qui était nécessaire pour
protéger nos entreprises et nos salariés
face à l'inflation à la crise du covid
mais qui aujourd'hui serait totalement
inappropriée nous sortirons du quoi
qu'il en coûte nous mettrons fin
progressivement au bouclier énergétique
et nous mettrons fin au chèque
exceptionnel le troisième pilier de
cette stratégie que nous avons définie
avec la première ministre c'est
d'engager nos revues des dépenses
publiques sur chacun des secteurs de
dépenses publiques pour nous assurer
tout simplement que l'argent public est
bien employé et que chaque euro d'argent
public qui est un euro du contribuable
gagné par le travail de contribuables
est utile pour nos services publics
utile pour nos compatriotes c'est comme
cela que nous tiendrons nos objectifs et
que nous serons sous les 3% de déficit
en 2027 et que nous accélérerons le
désendettement du pays je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Thibault François pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Pape
Ndiaye ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse de France le savoir
est de beaucoup la portion la plus
considérable du bonheur disait sofocs
dans sa tragédie Antigone tragique c'est
la définition même de la situation des
personnes porteuses de handicapées
intellectuel dans mon département le
Nord mais également dans la France
entière sous votre gouvernement ils sont
plus de 8000 porteurs de handicap
intellectuels dans le département du
Nord à ne pas bénéficier d'une prise en
charge adaptée selon l'association Les
Papillons blancs dont plus de 900 seuls
dans le Douaisis tragique c'est la
lettre de mise en demeure qu'on reçut
les parents des enfants de
l'établissement pour enfants et
adolescents polyhandicapés de Féchin
dans ma circonscription lettre qui a été
signée de votre main pour je cite non
scolarisation de leurs enfants alors que
les parents ont toutes les peines du
monde à trouver des établissements
adaptés pour leurs enfants tragique
c'est l'état de notre système
d'éducation qui laisse sur le côté ses
enfants sans instruction ainsi que des
parents dans un état de détresse
incommensurable affechin comme dans
beaucoup d'établissements d'accueil les
enfants sont gérés regroupés dans la
salle commune sans éveil particulier
sans programmer éducatif adapté malgré
tout le développement tout le dévouement
du personnel soignant vous êtes coupable
coupable de ne pas respecter notre
Constitution qui garantit l'égalité dans
l'éducation pour tous et à tous les
degrés oui pour tous ma question est
simple monsieur le ministre comptez-vous
faire quelque chose pour appliquer le
principe d'égalité qui est un principe
constitutionnel et permettre à ses
enfants de bénéficier d'une éducation
adaptée à leur handicap et donc
d'accéder au savoir à la découverte à
l'éveil et donc au bonheur je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Thibault François
je
cette question je me pencherai sur le
cas spécifique que vous venez d'indiquer
mais je voudrais d'abord faire une
remarque générale c'est celle des plus
de 430 000 enfants en situation de
handicap que l'école scolarise
aujourd'hui c'est trois fois plus qu'en
2005 lorsque la loi a été votée nous
avons et je l'ai moi-même reconnu devant
vous Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires nous avons un certain
nombre de difficultés aujourd'hui dans
l'école inclusive difficulté auxquelles
la conférence nationale sur le handicap
qui s'est tenu notamment dans sa
fonction conclusive le 26 avril dernier
essaie de répondre voilà les mesures que
nous mettons en place avec la ministre
Geneviève dariussec tout d'abord tous
les enfants en situation de handicap
bénéficieront d'un numéro national
d'identification à la rentrée c'était
une demande des familles et des
associations depuis longtemps ensuite
nous améliorons la situation des aesh
avec un recrutement de 4000 aosh à la
rentrée une augmentation de 10% et
également
un rapprochement avec la vie scolaire
pour tendre vers les 35 heures nous
faisons également des pials avec
Geneviève darrieussec une instance en
amont de la notification des MDPH de
discussions avec la famille de
scolarisation des enfants cela concerne
aussi les enfants qui souffrent de
handicap intellectuels ceux auxquels
vous faites allusion dans votre
circonscription je vais me pencher sur
ce cas que je ne connais pas précisément
et je vous apporterai une réponse
circonstanciée quoi qu'il en soit notre
détermination à la min Istre et à
moi-même est entière pour la
scolarisation des saints enfants
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je suis désolé mais je crois
que votre réponse est loin d'être à la
hauteur des enjeux parce que vous dites
que vous connaissez pas la situation de
ma circonscription je viens de vous
citer plus de 8000 personnes porteur de
handicap qui sont dans le département du
Nord et je vais sûrement vous annoncer
quelque chose vous êtes probablement au
courant que en Belgique beaucoup
d'établissements sont en faire sont en
train de fermer en ce moment même et
donc tous les reports sont en train de
se faire sur le département du Nord et
dans le reste de la France donc je suis
navré mais je crains que votre réponse
ne soit pas satisfaisante monsieur le
ministre
merci la parole est à Monsieur Michel
salade le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture le 24 mai 2023
après consultation du comité ressources
en eau la préfète du Gard a signé la
version définitive de l'arrêté cadre
sécheresse la moitié du département est
en situation de crise et l'irrigation
des cultures est interdite les
Pyrénées-Orientales l'eau de les
Bouches-du-Rhône et d'autres
départements connaissent des situations
similaires selon le GIEC cette situation
anormale sera de plus en plus fréquente
et dans quelques décennies deviendra la
règle pour la région méditerranéenne
anticipé permettra de ne pas être
confronté à des choix très violents
d'ici 10 ou à 20 à 20 ou 20 ans l'eau
est un bien commun en raréfaction
lakarement de cette ressource par une
minorité via la construction de méga
bassines provoque déjà des tensions
insupportables alors ce n'est pas tout
de mettre en place des arrêtés
sécheresse il faut envisager
immédiatement une planification à plus
long terme pour éviter des crises de
plus en plus graves il n'existe pas de
solution unique pour tout le territoire
les agriculteurs agricultrices
connaissent leur terroir et savent ce
qu'il y est possible d'y faire il y aura
des pertes de production pour de
nombreuses cultures pour la boriculture
et la viticulture les plans sont déjà
fragilisés par les épisodes de
sécheresse précédent et les conséquences
se feront sentir sur le long terme alors
la loi du 2 mars 2022
Emmanuel Macron a fait le choix de
favoriser le secteur privé des
assurances plutôt que d'élargir
efficacement le fond de solidarité
nationale depuis le 1er janvier 2023 les
agriculteurs sont incités à souscrire
une assurance récolte pour être mieux
indemnisée mais certaines compagnies
d'assurance imposent une clause
d'exclusion d'indemnisation en cas de
restriction administrative d’eau d'usage
de l'eau les agriculteurs sont pris en
étau à cela s'ajoutent des niveaux
d'indemnisation qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur des pertes augmenter le taux de
compensation et le conditionner à
l'engagement dans une démarche
d'adaptation des cultures au changement
climatique serait une solution un début
de solution dans mon département les
petites exploitations représentent 65%
des producteurs elles n'ont pas toujours
la trésorerie pour affronter ces
nouvelles crises monsieur le ministre
entendez-vous la détresse du monde
agricole qu'allez-vous faire pour faire
se soutenir la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Michel Sala d'abord
vous avez cité cette ce comité
ressources en eau qui s'est tenu le 24
mai qui a été l'occasion pour la
préfecture du Gard à la fois de valider
la crise sur la 16 sur le vidéo sur le
Gardon et plus largement de rappeler les
zones qui sont concernées par l'alerte
par l'alerte renforcée et de poser ce
nouvel arrêté 4 sécheresse il y a dans
votre question au-delà de la dimension
locale dont on aura à rediscuter très
bientôt compte tenu des enjeux
particuliers du dérèglement climatique
et de la Camargue qui a donné lieu à un
rapport qui est en cours de finalisation
pour regarder comment le dérèglement
climatique et la salinisation qui touche
de façon plus particulière ce territoire
mérite d'être pris en compte et d'être
accompagné mais votre question va
au-delà elle pose la question de
l'adaptation y compris de notre système
assurantiel au dérèglement climatique et
à ce qu'il entraîne en termes de
bouleversement
c'est au cœur de la stratégie
d'adaptation d'une France à 4 degrés que
nous avons lancé il y a quelques
semaines dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent dans les chantiers il y a
la révision des référentiels techniques
et il y a en parallèle cette question du
rythme de ce qu'on appelle par le passé
des catastrophes naturelles qui si elle
se reproduisent du retrait gonflement
d'argile des difficultés sur les pertes
de récolte vont nécessiter une refonte
de notre système assurantiel lié à cette
transition on est dans cette
planification on se bat pour faire en
sorte de baisser nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre l'année 2022 nous a
permis à nouveau de respecter nos quotas
carbone et on se bat dans le même temps
contenu du fait que le monde n'est pas
sur la bonne trajectoire comme le dit le
GIEC pour nous préparer aux conséquences
d'un réchauffement qui est déjà là et
pour lequel nous avons à anticiper de ce
point de vue il faut du travail il faut
de la constance il faut de la cohérence
et il faut se garder des formules toutes
faites je vous remercie de l'esprit dans
lequel vous avez posé cette question
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Marcelin Nadeau
pour le groupe GDR merci madame la
présidente monsieur le garde des sous
ministre de la Justice vous êtes rendu
récemment aux Antilles avait pu
constater la situation qu'on vient
difficile d'exercice des missions de
justice en Martinique comme en
Guadeloupe bien que préoccupant
également dans l'Hexagone la situation
des prisons est dramatique dans les 10
outre-mer c'est vrai aux Antilles mais
ça l'est aussi à la Réunion comme
indiqué par nos collègues réunionnais et
à Mayotte comme la pièce le mouvement de
grève qui touche depuis hier la prison
en effet je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur les 100 pénitentiaires
dans nos régions qui ne disposent
d'aucune unité hospitalière de soins
UHSA quant à la prise en charge
psychiatrique ou UHSI pour les aspects
somatiques des centres pénitentiaires
qui ne disposent non plus ni des risques
et qui régional d'intervention de la
sécurité ni de prêche pour les
extractions judiciaires en Martinique il
s'agissant de la prise en charge
médicale des détenus il n'y a que 5
chambres sanitaires carcérales au CHUM
de Fort-de-France et nous avons pu
constater lors d'une visite leur état
d'extrême indignité indigne d'un état
républicain la Martinique la Guadeloupe
comme la Guyane et la Réunion en
pourtant grand besoin de ces unités
sanitaires spécialisées car elles sont
frappées d'une double peine une
population carcérale qui vieillit à donc
besoin de soins plus réguliers plus
constant d'une part et une population
corsicale qui paraît doxalement rajeunit
d'autre part avec des pathologies
spécifiques nécessitant un
accompagnement sanitaire et surtout
psychologique magistrat médecin
professionnel pénitentiaire sont
unanimes il faut implanter UHSA UHSI et
ris et prêt Jean-Marc unique comme en
Guadeloupe et à la Réunion d'ailleurs ma
question est donc simple monsieur le
ministre a quand l'implantation de ces
structures dans nos pays afin de
résorber cette courbe importante est
grave inégalités structurelle entre
l'hexagone et les 10 outre-mer
régulièrement la Martinique merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre
délégué chargé du renouveau démocratique
et porte-parole du gouvernement
la présidence mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député marcelinado
j'excuse de garder sauts parce qu'il est
au bord un autre banque celui-ci il est
au Sénat en ce moment même pour
consacrer justement de nouveaux moyens à
notre système de justice dans le cadre
du projet de loi dédié vous posez des
questions évidemment légitimes c'est un
sujet que nous prenons très au sérieux
comme le ministre de la Justice tout
d'abord vous savez qu'il y a un plan de
15000 places de prison qui est
actuellement mise en oeuvre et qui
constitue un levier pérenne de manière à
réduire la surpopulation carcérale
améliorée de fait les conditions de
détention et de travail pour les
personnels ensuite monsieur le député
j'ajoute que le ministre de la Justice
et vous l'avez dit dans votre question
merci c'est très récemment rendu en
Martinique et vous connaissez toute son
attention pour votre territoire il a
posé à Ducos le mois dernier la première
pierre d'une des 12 structures
d'accompagnement vers la sortie du
territoire national il y a également
inauguré le premier atelier en outre-mer
du service de l'emploi pénitentiaire qui
permet aux détenus qui le souhaitent de
travailler
et les services de l'administration
pénitentiaire avec ceux de l'hôpital
travail à améliorer concrètement la
prise en charge des détenus qui
nécessitent des soins s'il ne peut
aujourd'hui vous être annoncé
formellement la création du Hassi ou du
hsea en fin d'année ce sont désormais 8
chambres sécurisées qui seront
disponibles à l'hôpital pour assurer une
prise en charge somatique mais aussi
psychiatrique la plus adaptée possible
une feuille de route santé justice 2023
2028 est actuellement en cours de
finalisation de manière à améliorer
l'ensemble des dispositifs dédiés à
cette prise en charge sanitaire des
détenus de même la sécurité
pénitentiaire c'est une préoccupation
majeure du garde une équipe locale de
sécurité pénitentiaire sera déployée à
l'automne prochain à Ducos le type ce
type de démarche de déploie évidemment
également dans les autres territoires
ultramarins que vous avez cité
loutre-mer est éloigné géographiquement
mais très présente dans l'action de nos
ministère et puis généralement du
gouvernement je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre vous avez deux secondes la
position que nous avons c'est que les
ministres font un petit tour et puis
s'en vont et nos problèmes ressentiés
donnez-nous ces structures nous en avons
besoin merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Michel perron
pour le groupe Renaissance
oui madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Jean-Christophe combe
ministre des Solidarités le président de
la République s'était engagé à garantir
à chaque jeune enfant une plaque une
place excusez-moi d'accueil suite à de
nombreuses concertations la première
ministre madame la Première ministre a
présenté les premières mesures du
service public de la petite enfance
jeudi 1er juin le gouvernement s'engage
à répondre à une inquiétude légitime des
parents par la création de ce service
public que vous placez sous la
responsabilité des communes nous
répondrons au plus près aux
préoccupations des parents en pouvant
leur apporter une solution cohérente
avec leurs besoins notamment grâce à la
création des relais petite enfance qui
leur apporteront les informations
nécessaires
le gouvernement sera aux côtés des
communes pour la mise en place du SPE
donc service public de la petite enfance
notamment face à la pénurie des places
d'accueil en consentant un
investissement massif de 5,5 milliards
d'euros pour atteindre l'ouverture de
100000 places supplémentaires à horizon
2027 puis 300 000 à horizons 2030
garantir l'accueil de chaque jeune
enfant est un enjeu d'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes c'est un enjeu pour
le plein emploi et la reprise d'une
activité professionnelle pour les femmes
cet accueil doit être réellement
universel pour répondre aux besoins de
toutes les familles et de tous les
jeunes enfants que ce soit des familles
monoparentales des familles à horaires
dit atypiques des familles précaires ou
des parents sans emploi et enfin que les
enfants soient en situation de handicap
ou non la qualité de l'accueil du jeune
enfant reste la priorité c'est pourquoi
vous lancez des concertations sur des
référentiels nationaux monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous revenir plus
précisément sur les contenus des mesures
relatives à l'accueil du jeûne enfant et
sur les concertations en cours merci
Merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
con ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Michel perron je vous remercie pour
votre question qui me permet en effet de
revenir sur les annonces faites par
madame la Première ministre jeudi
dernier à Angers concernant le service
public de la petite enfance c'était une
promesse un engagement du Président de
la République pendant sa campagne
engagement à créer 200000 places
d'accueil pour les enfants de 0 à 3 ans
d'ici à 2030 alors il y a urgence
urgence parce que c'est sans doute le
sujet le plus important pour les
familles de notre pays aujourd'hui en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il demande c'est un
frein majeur à l'emploi et c'est un
sujet qui est au carrefour de plusieurs
priorités vous l'avez dit d'abord la
politique du plein emploi aujourd'hui
c'est 150000 personnes qui renoncent à
un emploi pour pouvoir accompagner leur
enfant c'est un sujet qui vise à lutter
aussi contre les inégalités de destin je
rappelle que 5% des enfants des familles
les plus modestes seulement ont une
place en crèche contre 20% pour les
familles les plus aisées il y a un enjeu
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et puis c'est un enjeu également pour la
natalité dans notre pays cette réforme
c'est le fruit de longs mois de
concertation avec l'ensemble des acteurs
du secteur qui va nous permettre de
proposer davantage de solutions aux
parents qui soient accessibles abordable
sur l'ensemble du territoire mais aussi
d'assurer de meilleures conditions
d'exercices pour l'ensemble des
professionnels il y a deux volets dans
ces propositions un volet qualitatif
c'est à dire que on va assurer des
mesures d'amélioration de l'accueil pour
le bien-être des enfants mais aussi des
contrôles et j'annonceraient d'ici à la
fin du mois de juin un plan d'urgence
qui reprend les recommandations du
rapport de l'Inspection générale des
affaires sociales pour la qualité et
puis il y a un volet quantit Atif là on
va faire des communes du bloc communal
une autorité organisatrice en donnant
qui donnera aussi au CAF en dernier
ressort la possibilité de créer les
places d'accueil nécessaires c'est un
investissement inédit massif vous l'avez
dit de près de 6 milliards d'euros qui
seront déployés d'ici à 2027
merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
Bricout pour le groupe liote
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre du Logement au fil des mois
vous faites du logement une bombe
sociale enfin vous semblez en tous les
cas réagir en convoquant le Conseil
national de la refondation pourtant vos
premières conclusions sur le prêt à taux
zéro sur la suppression du PNL et j'en
passe interroge d'une part les
parlementaires et scandalisent le
secteur on est trop loin du compte on
est trop loin des bonnes trajectoires
sociales et environnementales monsieur
le ministre convenait en le Seigneur ne
peut être un point final alors bien sûr
on a rien contre la démocratie
participative mais vous devez en fin de
compte l'articulé avec la démocratie par
parlementaire avant de prendre des
décisions ici nous sommes nombreuses et
nombreux à vouloir poursuivre le débat
un plancher sur le sujet à proposer même
d'ailleurs avec mes collègues marjolaine
Menier millefer et Judy leernuss la
mission d'information que je préside
s'attarde sur la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments au fil des auditions on
constate quoi on constate un marché
complètement exposé à la fraude un
manque de visibilité de stabilité des
dispositifs une politique par geste qui
n'a pas montré d'ailleurs son efficacité
un soutien financier quel souvent
insuffisant pour les plus modestes
encore une fois ce CNR n'y répond en
rien pourtant des solutions existent
pour déclencher cette envie de rénover
pour mieux coopérer avec les
collectivités pour renouer avec la
confiance pourra peut-être un premier
contact mieux identifier sur nos
territoires pour en accompagnement
quelquefois techniques financier ou
quelquefois même social dans tous les
cas qu'on espère toujours approprié
d'ailleurs vous proposez mon
accompagnateur rénov mais son profil ces
missions sont floues ils vous faudrait
certainement aussi mieux valoriser le
prêt avancer bref il reste encore
beaucoup de choses à faire monsieur le
ministre encore une fois vos décisions
après le CNR ne sont pas à la hauteur
des enjeux quand allez-vous nous
proposer un texte pour débattre et
peut-être intégrer nos propositions
merci merci beaucoup coucou la parole
est à Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Jean-Louis Bricout oui vous avez raison
l'ambition écologique à traverser à
irriguer l'ensemble des travaux du CNR
et à mon tour je remercie votre collègue
marjolaine de son implication de son
animation avec Christine Lecomte la
présidente de l'Ordre des architectes de
ce groupe de travail sur la rénovation
énergétique j'en profite aussi pour vous
remercier comme je remercie l'ensemble
des parlementaires quel que soit les
banques et quel que soit ce que j'ai pu
entendre aujourd'hui de la mobilisation
sur les questions du logement et je les
invite aussi à écouter et à rencontrer
l'ensemble des animateurs du CNR vous
verrez que leurs réaction que leur
propositions sont parfois un peu moins
caricatural que ce que j'ai pu entendre
aujourd'hui et oui bien évidemment
madame la Première ministre l'a dit hier
je l'ai dit tout au long de la journée
le Conseil national de la refondation ça
restitution d'hier et tout sauf final
c'est une invitation à continuer à
continuer à travailler ensemble sur la
question de la rénovation énergétique un
certain nombre de propositions ont été
faites hier dans la continuité de ce qui
a déjà été fait je le rappelle 1,5
millions de chantiers les économies
d'énergie de l'équivalent d'une ville
comme Lyon qui ont été gagné grâce à ses
travaux mais oui il faut des chantiers
plus performants plus globaux pour
réussir la transformation écologique et
énergétique il a été annoncé hier plus
de 200 chantiers globaux en 2024 c'est
extrêmement important il a été annoncé
une augmentation extrêmement importante
du nombre d'accompagnateurs rénov car
les Français ont besoin d'être
accompagnés de savoir ce qu'ils ont à
dépenser et surtout de savoir quels
effets sera sur leur compte en banque et
oui nous travaillons avec Bruno Le Maire
et allons avec l'ensemble des des
instituts bancaires à améliorer l'éco
PTZ à le rendre plus facile nous
travaillons aussi sur le reste à charge
notamment sur le prêt avance rénovation
que vous avez cité qui un bon outil qui
doit nous permettre de multiplier les
effets de ma prime rénov je vous
remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ministre de l'Industrie à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé messieurs vous
déclariez le 3 février dernier dans un
communiqué commun que je cite la
mobilisation du gouvernement est totale
pour préserver l'accès des Français aux
médicaments sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais le 13 avril la direction de Sanofi
annonçait la suppression de 135 postes
dans deux de ces usines françaises 70 à
Ramon dans le Gard et 65 assisterons
dans ma circonscription des Alpes de
Haute-Provence soit plus de 10% des
effectifs sur ce même site de Sisteron
un bâtiment de production devrait être
tout bonnement rasé ces décisions font
suite aux 265 suppressions de poste sur
le site de production de vaccins de
Marcy-l'Étoile et s'inscrivent dans une
stratégie de long terme de Sanofi le
démantèlement de sa filière de principe
actifs cette stratégie prévoit d'ici
2025 la vente et donc l'abandon de la
production de 400 molécules jugées trop
peu rentables la rentabilité pour Sanofi
ce n'est pas l'intérêt des patients
c'est la garantie de faire plus de 30%
de marge sinon on vend
or ces 15 dernières années sanofi a
touché plus d'un milliard et demi
d'argent public sous forme de cice ou de
crédit d'impôt recherche dans le même
temps l'entreprise supprimée pourtant
7700 postes dont près de 50% des postes
de chercheurs fermez celle-ci en France
et versez plus de 30 milliards de
dividendes à ses actionnaires mais
question sont donc les suivantes
monsieur le ministre de l'Industrie que
comptez-vous faire pour empêcher Sanofi
de détruire des emplois et de sacrifier
sur l'Hôtel des super profits un outil
industriel essentiel à notre pays
monsieur le ministre de la Santé que
comptez-vous faire pour assurer la
souveraineté thérapeutique française et
rappeler Sanofi à ses obligations de
production et de détention de stocks
minimum de médicaments enfin messieurs
les ministres que comptez-vous faire
pour contrôler l'utilisation des fonds
publics par Sanofi et les autres et
quand allez-vous vous décider à mettre
en place un pôle public du médicament
seul garantie d'une production
pharmaceutique efficace au service de
l'intérêt général je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Roland Lescure ministre rechargé de
l'industrie merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député Léo Walter merci de votre
question ou merci de votre slogans merci
de vos incantations merci de votre
volonté comme toujours
[Applaudissements]
comme toujours de tout nationaliser donc
loin de ces slogans et ses incantations
ça fait maintenant deux ans presque jour
pour jour que le Président de la
République a annoncé un plan France 2030
d'investissement fort dans la santé de
manière à régler le vrai triangle de
l'impensible auquel fait face la
politique industrielle de la santé
française à la fois nous souhaitons
soigner les Françaises et les Français
nous souhaitons le faire un court
raisonnable et nous souhaitons faire oui
en produisant davantage en France et
nous le faisons via de l'investissement
auquel les entreprises françaises et les
entreprises internationales sont
sensibles aujourd'hui puisque ne vous en
déplaisent de plus en plus d'entreprises
y compris internationale choisissent le
terrain France pour s'y installer nous
l'avons fait aussi sur les principes
actifs vous le savez nous rapatrions le
principe actif du paracétamol à séquence
pas très loin de chez vous au nord de
votre circonscription à quelques à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de
manière à repro duire du principe actif
de paracétamol en France en ce qui
concerne le groupe sanofil et les
suppressions d'emploi auxquelles vous
faites référence vous le savez
innover investir suppose aussi parfois
malheureusement de fermer des
installations qui elles sont obsolides
et vous le savez monsieur puisque vous
connaissez bien votre territoire
contrairement à vos voisins qui hurlent
mais nous m'écoutent pas les deux
ateliers qui sont en cours de fermeture
vous le savez date de plus de 50 ans
vous le savez aussi monsieur le député
les 135 emplois qui malheureusement
doivent être supprimés le seront sur la
base de départ volontaire le seront sur
la palte reclassement et avec mon
collègue en charge du plein emploi de
l'insertion nous assurons que Sanofi
remplit les engagements auxquels ils se
sont faits et enfin avec mon collègue de
la santé nous mettons tout en œuvre pour
assurer que la souveraineté sanitaire
sera assurée
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Géraldine
Grangier pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué chargé des
transports monsieur le ministre non les
3,9 millions de motards ne sont pas des
idiots et c'est Bernard de mon
département qui le dit on sait que si on
monte sur une moto pourrie on le paie
cache monsieur le ministre le Conseil
d'État vous a donné deux mois pour vous
mettre en conformité avec la législation
européenne adoptée en 2014 et prendre un
décret d'application pour la mise en
place du contrôle technique des deux
roues motorisés toutefois si le Conseil
d'État voulait agir en faveur d'une
meilleure protection des motards il
aurait dû mieux lire les statistiques en
disant le nombre de deux roues motorisés
à augmenter de 30%. alors que le nombre
de tués a baissé de 19%
seul 03% des accidents sont liés à un
défaut technique alors que 30% des
accidents comportent un facteur causal
lié aux infrastructures routières
monsieur le ministre pensez-vous qu'un
contrôle technique payant améliorera la
sécurité et les performances
environnementales des motards avec la
mise en place des normes européennes et
l'amélioration des performances
environnementales les deux roues
motorisées ne sont responsables que de
0,5% des émissions polluantes et
contribuent fortement à fluidifier le
trafic plutôt qu'un contrôle technique
inefficace sur l'accidentologie et la
pollution les motards réclament la mise
en place des mesures alternatives visant
à améliorer la sécurité routière et la
performance environnementale comme
l'autorise la directive européenne
ce contrôle technique est une véritable
injustice dictée par quelques lobbyistes
et idéologues monsieur le ministre
laissez les motards s'occuper de l'état
de leur moto et occupez-vous de l'état
des routes alors monsieur le ministre à
quand la mise en place de la totalité
des mesures alternatives au contrôle
technique la parole est à monsieur
Clément bonne ministre chargé des
transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame la députée
Grangier vous citez Bernard de votre
circonscription j'ai rencontré le très
nombreuses reprises les associations
représentant les motards j'ai entendu
ces préoccupations cet argument aussi
même si je crois que celui-ci en
particulier doit être légèrement nuancé
parce que on pourrait dire aussi
qu'aucun automobiliste n'a envie de
prendre une voiture je pense que c'est
de bon sens qui serait aussi un danger
néanmoins le gouvernement en effet
privilégié depuis le longues années de
longs mois encore ces derniers mois les
mesures dites alternatives au contrôle
technique notre interprétation était que
la directive européenne que vous citez
laissez cette possibilité ouverte et une
minorité mais quelques pays européens
néanmoins ont fait jusqu'à ce jour ce
choix même si la plupart d'entre eux
sont aussi en train d'évoluer néanmoins
madame la député nous sommes dans un
état de droit et les droits le droit
national ou européen est interprété par
le juge la loi est votée soit au niveau
européen soit au niveau national par le
Parlement et c'est le juge qui
interprète ensuite les choses et donc ce
n'est pas moi un niveau qui pouvait dire
si les mesures alternatives sont
autorisées ou non dans la directive
c'est ce que nous souhaitions c'était
notre interprétation par deux fois le
Conseil d'État a indiqué que ce n'était
pas la lecture juridique qu'il fallait
faire après la décision de fin d'année
dernière j'ai engagé une concertation
longue approfondie détaillée avec les
associations de motards pour répondre au
maximum à leurs préoccupations le
Conseil d'État nous a maintenant donné
deux mois pour agir définitivement sur
ce sujet et donc je le dis en vérité
sans démagogie il faudra mettre en place
un contrôle technique car nous sommes
dans un état nous respectons les règles
interprétées par les juges c'est ainsi
que cela fonctionne néanmoins je veux
que les choses soient les plus
progressives possible et moins
pénalisantes possible et moins coûteuses
possibles et dans le même esprit de
dialogue je recevrai donc ce jeudi les
associations de motards pour discuter
avec eux du calendrier des modalités
sans faux semblant et sans illusion il
faudra engager le contrôle technique
mais je veux le faire de la manière la
plus respectueuse efficace possible
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel
Mondon pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des Affaires étrangères
cette nuit en Ukraine sabotage a détruit
partiellement une infrastructure civile
majeure le barrage hydroélectrique de
cacovka les conséquences de ce crime de
guerre sont tragiques et à l'heure où
nous sommes réunis nous constatons des
villes et villages ont été engloutis des
dizaines de milliers d'Ukrainiens
luttent pour leur survie la centrale de
saporiccia menacée de surchauffe et
surveiller de très près par l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique une
catastrophe écologique sans précédent à
l'échelle de plusieurs régions ce profil
madame la ministre pourriez-vous
nous communiquer les dernières
informations dont vous disposez sur
cette catastrophe avant nous une idée
précise de l'aide d'urgence qui pourrait
être apportées à nos amis Ukrainiens
mais au-delà cet événement nous rappelle
que Vladimir Poutine Krel ko qu'il avait
annoncé en pratiquant la terreur
systématique par la terre brûlée et
aujourd'hui les terres inondées nous
sommes au 16e mois d'une guerre
de haute intensité qui s'enlise
s'élargit révèle une escalade constante
dans les destructions et les menaces
nous allons ainsi au fil des mois de
sidération sidération l'Europe par la
voie du président Charles Michel affirmé
ce matin que la Russie devrait rendre
des comptes dans ce contexte effrayant
madame la ministre pourriez-vous nous
préciser si la France compte de
nouvelles initiatives diplomatiques à
l'encontre de la Russie pour dénoncer
son action criminelle et la placer face
à ses responsabilités devant l'histoire
je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
vous avez raison nouveau seuil a été
franchi avec la destruction partielle du
barrage de kakovka il s'agit évidemment
d'un acte grave d'un acte inexcusable
odieux qui auront en effet des
conséquences durables sur la vie de
milliers de milliers d'Ukrainiens déjà
meurtri par la guerre et qui ont dû être
évacués de plus cet acte met en danger
l'environnement et l'avenir des récoltes
et il menace aussi de façon
irresponsable la sécurité de la centrale
nucléaire civile de zaporridja ils sont
ce point nous sommes en contact avec le
directeur général de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique qui
nous a confirmé le caractère très
préoccupant de la situation tout en
indiquant que pour l'heure le pire avait
été évité mais que il restait inquiet
car il craint une dégradation qui
pourrait être une dégradation rapide
par ailleurs vous savez monsieur le
député que l'Ukraine a demandé une
réunion d'urgence du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies
alors que la Russie cherche à semer le
doute sur l'origine de ce sabotage nous
ne devons pas perdre de vue un fait
simple c'est la Russie cette elle seule
qui porte la responsabilité de cette
situation c'est elle qui a engagé cette
guerre c'est elle qui bombarde qui tue
qui détruit les infrastructures civiles
au service de son projet impérialiste
autant que illégal alors la France et
ses partenaires sont lucides autant
qu'ils sont déterminés nous continuerons
de condamner les exactions commises par
la Russie de lui demander de rendre des
comptes et oui nous poursuivrons
l'accélération de notre soutien
militaire pour que l'agression russe ne
soit pas récompensée pour que une paix
juste et durable puisse s'établir le
moment venu je vous remercie monsieur le
député
et Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Aurélien Tachet pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues ma question s'adressera
aussi à madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères alors Ousmane Sonko principal
opposant au président Macky Sall au
Sénégal vient d'être condamné à 2 ans de
prison dans des conditions extrêmement
troubles et risque ainsi de ne pas
pouvoir participer aux élections
présidentielles l'année prochaine la
situation est là-bas explosive et madame
la ministre permettez-moi de vous dire
que la réponse de la France n'est pas à
la hauteur pas la hauteur parce que les
affrontements entre la police et les
manifestants déjà fait au moins 16 morts
on ne compte plus les arrestations
arbitraires les coupures de messagerie
des réseaux sociaux et même par
intermittence de l'ensemble d'internet
depuis dimanche l'Université Cheikh Anta
Diop de Dakar la plus grande du pays a
été fermée jusqu'à nouvel ordre et on
évoque désormais la présence de nervy au
côté de la police des informations qui
vont dans le sens des dizaines de vidéos
que je reçois depuis plusieurs jours je
me suis en effet rendu au Sénégal le
mois dernier et j'ai eu l'occasion
pendant les cinq jours que j'ai passé
sur place de rencontrer de nombreux
opposants ONG ou représentants de la
jeunesse qui tous m'ont dit la même
chose nous ne laisserons pas le
président Macky Sall nous voler les
élections la présidentielles l'année
prochaine pas à la hauteur non plus donc
parce que la dérive autoritaire en cours
dans ce pays a désormais franchi un
nouveau cap faisons naître une forte
inquiétude quand on respecte de la
démocratie au Sénégal l'affaire son cou
n'est d'ailleurs pas la seule qui a
conduit à mettre des opposants de la de
l'actuel président en jeu Karim Wade par
exemple ont connu le même sort donc ça
on remet en cause la justice sénégalaise
de réelles questions se pose quant à son
instrumentalisation par le pouvoir en
place pas à la hauteur enfin parce que
dès le 27 mars dernier je vous avais
écrit madame la ministre un courrier sur
la situation politique inquiétante au
Sénégal dans une réponse reçue jeudi
dernier vous m'avez indiqué que le
gouvernement français serait attentif à
la préparation et au déroulement du
processus électoral à venir dans ce pays
pourtant malgré la tournure extrêmement
grave compris les événements ces
derniers jours ni vous ni le président
de la République à qui j'ai écrit aussi
non réagi ce silence ne peut que
renforcer un sentiment anti-français
jusqu'ici très largement contenu dans ce
pays alors que nous avons déjà été
chassés du Mali ou du Burkina Faso cette
parole madame la ministre est pourtant
très attendue des Sénégalais alors ma
question est simple la France va-t-elle
se murer dans un silence coupable sur ce
qui se passe à Dakar et se
prépare-t-elle à reconnaître un
troisième mandat du président Macky Sall
pourtant interdit par la Constitution
sénégalaise fruit Sénégal
ou la parole est à Madame Catherine
Colonna ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
tâché les violences qui ont éclaté au
Sénégal la semaine dernière nous
inquiète oui et la France je suis sûr
que vous l'avez vu cette exprimé en ce
sens depuis le début des événements et
vous le savez très bien monsieur le
député dans ces violences de trop
nombreuses personnes ont perdu la vie et
souvent de très jeunes personnes des
enfants et je voudrais bien sûr adresser
ici mes condoléances à leur famille et
souhaiter un prompt rétablissement à
tous les blessés nous sommes extrêmement
préoccupés je le redis parce que le
Sénégal est un pays ami et un partenaire
important pour la France et ici comme
là-bas nous avons une importante
diaspora des communautés qui font aussi
le ciment de notre relation
alors en tant que ami et partenaire du
Sénégal nous sommes profondément
attachés à la longue tradition de
démocratie de paix de stabilité de ce
pays et en tant qu'ami et partenaire du
Sénégal nous appelons une nouvelle fois
tous les Sénégalais tous les Sénégalais
à faire preuve de retenue à s'abstenir
de toute violence et à résoudre cette
crise par le dialogue en tant qu'ami et
partenaire du Sénégal nous passons ce
message monsieur le député sans relâche
non doutez pas et aux autorités comme à
l'opposition puisque nous parlons à tout
le monde et personnellement j'ai
confiance dans la capacité du peuple
sénégalais à résoudre cette crise à
sortir de ce moment difficile par un
dialogue inclusif Pacifique démocratique
de façon en effet à ce que les élections
de 2024 puissent se dérouler dans le
respect des règles de la démocratie et
du droit et dans la tradition de ce pays
je vous remercie je vous remercie madame
la ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-François portarieux pour le groupe
horizon
la transition numérique
l'intelligence artificielle est partout
dans nos téléphones dans nos voitures
dans nos banques nos hôpitaux elle est
dans cette hémicycle avec la LPM que
nous venons d'examiner à travers le la
question du soldaté il a été question à
Paris l'autre jour avec la présence du
créateur de chat GPT elle était encore
là mardi soir avec Étienne Klein à
l'occasion de l'assemblée des idées et
elle sera la semaine prochaine au
Parlement européen qui aura un vote à
faire sur le sujet c'est un sujet qui ne
relève pas qui nous relève plus de la
science-fiction mais de la balistique
l'intelligence artificielle est une nuée
de projectile dont nous ignorons la
taille et les moments de l'impact mais
nous savons déjà que les effets seront
fulgurants les développements de ces
technologies vont bouleverser en cascade
nos modèles sociaux et notre rapport au
réel
s'il est sort de l'intelligence
artificielle générative présente des
effets bénéfiques et vertueux elle
constitue aussi des risques et des
menaces très fortes si on perd le
contrôle alors sensible perplexe
enthousiaste ou inquiet face aux
applications il apparaît difficile de
faire l'économie du sujet il va apparaît
difficile de se contenter de faire des
recommandations de lister les bonnes
pratiques ou dédicter des principes
chaque jour qui passe dans une grande
opacité les algorithmes affectent notre
accès à l'information à l'emploi ou
encore au crédit bien entendu il ne
s'agit pas d'entraver le progrès mais
d'assurer l'ordre démocratique si nous
tardons à agir on risque d'observer une
défiance généralisée chez nos
concitoyens qui à terme sera susceptible
de freiner les développements de
l'intelligence artificielle y compris
dans ce qu'il pourrait avoir de
bénéfiques alors monsieur le ministre ou
en sommes-nous des suites du rapport
parlementaire de Cédric Villani qui
recommandé en 2017
d'ouvrir la boîte noire de
l'intelligence artificielle en
développant l'évaluation citoyenne en
pensant les trois collectifs sur les
données ou en anticipant les systèmes
d'armes létales autonome
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Jean-Noël barreau ministre
rechargé de la transition numérique et
des télécommunications merci Madame la
présente mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député Jean-François
portarieux on vous remercie pour votre
question je vous assurer tout de suite
qu'elle m'a répondu n'a pas été préparée
à l'aide de l'intelligence artificielle
est réaffirmée que nous avons l'ardente
obligation de faire en sorte de voir se
développer en France et en Europe dans
les prochains mois des modèles
d'intelligence artificielle générative
d'abord parce que nous en avons les
moyens de Blaise Pascal dont nous fêtons
cette année le 400e anniversaire de
naissance à Hugo du mini le copain
lauréat de la médaille field en
mathématiques l'année dernière la 12ème
pour la France notre pays n'a jamais
cessé d'être une grande nation de
mathématiques et puis ensuite parce que
nous en avons besoin vous l'avez dit il
est hors de question que cette
technologie se retrouve entre les mains
de puissants intérêts privés qui
placeraient l'Europe dans une situation
de dépendance et par ailleurs nous
voulons mettre entre les mains de nos
concitoyens des outils qui soient au feu
de la langue et de la culture française
alors nous n'avons pas attendu tchat
Jipi pour agir il y a 5 ans à la suite
du rapport vinani le président de la
République a souhaité bâtir une
stratégie nationale pour l'intelligence
artificielle dotée de 1 milliard et demi
d'euros 5 ans plus tard 4 centres
d'excellence sont été créés dont l'un
dans votre département à Nice à Toulouse
mais également à Grenoble à Nice et à
Paris nous avons doublé le nombre de
diplômés dans la discipline nous avons
aujourd'hui 600 startups qui sont
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle et cette stratégie
nationale est prolongée dans le cadre de
France 2030 avec un milliard deux
d'euros supplémentaires qui vont être
enrichies pour tenir compte de l'arrivée
de l'intelligence artificielle
générative par un volet dédié que le
Président de la République annoncera la
semaine prochaine sans doute à
l'occasion de vivatech s'agissant de la
de la régulation puisque vous l'avez
abordé également avec la première
ministre avec le ministre de l'économie
et des finances nous veillons à ce qu'un
juste équilibre soit trouvé entre la
protection des citoyens et
l'encouragement à l'innovation le
rapport de votre collègue Philippe
Pradal sur le sujet éclairera les
décisions que nous aurons à prendre je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la séance des questions au
Gouvernement est terminée